[Music]
sure he'll be
back
[Music]
great
see
[Music]
I like your
birds
[Music]
there
up
[Music]
oh
KY check I out my last tweet call bday
out
[Music]
okay
finally oh man I's see that first show
of the Year let's go puzzle World
Championship TM live now chances Fe mess
me about this today guess in the
thread wow I got to rat this that's what
I'm talking about man I'm calling feed
day out let's goet
it
done
[Music]
okay it's
great hold chat muting my
laptop loving it loving that 30 second
[Music]
Mark are we streaming with any delay
today I assume not because it's not
something we have to stress
about we got Vapor it's not a fair play
thing I don't know all
right
[Music]
it's it's the puzzles World Championship
it is the year 2024 it's the way we like
to kick things off every New Year here
at chess.com Danny Ren
alongside Master James KY and KY it
feels good to start the year with some
if I don't say so myself we have puzzles
this is the best week of the year of
course it's anniversary for us here as
we see every year we back to back world
champion we got to get more time
together you know I know we were just
hanging with the FL W Flex so in Toronto
but right now we got other things to get
into we had a couple weeks there in
Canada but we've had one week of puzzles
here on chess.com going let's remind
everybody of what the community has been
up to so far it's been open to all
chess.com members Monday we had a chess
play quick for those who don't know that
that actually is often a monthly event
we do for our entire streaming Community
where they can throw down in some sort
of Gauntlet or Bounty event we threw
together this week of course puzzles
Tuesday we had the puzzle R challenge
followed by survival mode and today it's
the first day of the puzzles World
Championship don't stress me out don't
worry about that world championship name
cuz we doing it right here Cy your
thoughts on what we're about to see you
know what you're going to see some of
the best puzzle runs ever in fact I saw
like I'm trying to touch 50 49 so I'm
feel good I look at I'm like he got
extra 20 more than that un I don't have
time left trying to break the it's just
insane to see so I want to see some
records broken today he does things in
three minute that Masters can't do in
survival mode it's absolutely bananas
what that guy able we're going to talk
about rain a little bit but let's talk
about the format remind everybody what
we're about to get into we actually have
99 exactly streamers registered to throw
down in this first leg of the puzzles
World Championship maybe we'll get you
100 before this day is done but that is
a record it's five rounds where for 30
minutes people will stream their own
view you can follow it on Twitch on
YouTube on KCK wherever these people are
streaming to put up their best attempt K
and that attempt gets them in a ranking
system where the top 20 Advance round
two and in that moment we will then teir
the streamers off so even though they're
not directly battling each other that's
day two that's tomorrow where they will
play puzzle battles then they're faced
and the best the best puzzle rushers
will move on to the K where you and
Hilton will have theana and the bottom
three will go home what are the stakesy
we got $25,000 for our puzzles World
Championship that's for the whole K kood
top 20 finishers get at least 200 bucks
today and tomorrow you're getting at
least a cool one grand a cool I what is
the term we use for a grand these days
there's probably a sexier way to say a
grand I like to say thow
that sounds like a good rap name
like happened
to actually I have a theory that L bwow
and Jaden Smith are actually the same
person this
is you never see him in the same
room 2024 is a good year to start
conspiracy theories and we're going to
kick that one around to the internet and
see see what people
let's let's keep moving on CY tell
everybody what the goat of puzzles is
able to do on the internet that is Ray
Shay Robson this guy as we look at his
profile is the four-time and only puzzle
world champion we've ever had it's
absolutely insane will anybody ever
knock him off yeah I mean this is Big R
and have a nice day and whatever day he
wants it to be is going to happen Okay
that's what he does he controls the way
he controls everything when it comes to
these puzzles Ray is the man as you see
there look at his highest puzzle Rush
scores I was just mentioning 69 mine is
49 and to do what I do in 49 like all
right cool three minutes you know that
seems cool he does an extra 20 I am
absolutely blown out of here Danny with
that stat that's nasty it it's crazy I'm
looking at that 69 in 3 minutes of
puzzle Rush is is is a bananas it's a
bananas number the highest puzzle he's
ever solved in a 3-minute puzzle puzzle
Rush is higher than a lot of people's
all-time rating in Puzzles even even
those who are truly addicted to the
feature shout out to all of our crazy
puzzle solvers uh his puzzle rating na
um maybe because he hasn't actually
solved traditional puzzles in a long
time but I've told this story many times
because he just like he just too good
they a want to givez to do it Danny
exactly yeah it's like Neo stopping the
bullets in the first Matrix you knew the
scene was coming at some point he would
choose to be the one you didn't know how
he was going to do it and there you got
Ray just choosing Cho using to break the
system we can't even rank the dude
anymore but uh I I've told the story
many times about Ray cany but this guy
was trying to memorize puzzles as a kid
and I remember it really well and I
think a lot of people early on just had
no idea what what someone could be
capable of but if if it's possible for a
human being to memorize tens of
thousands of specific puzzles this guy
has been the closest ever person to do
it but let's talk about the guy who's
often right behind him Demetrus lulos
not the most well-known person in the
chess Community cuz he's not a grandm or
really even a an international Master he
is a feed Master hasn't played in a lot
of top professional events Cy but he's a
very strong player and an absolute
monster when it comes to puzzles it's
just a matter of time when he ever he is
ready to level up his title here as you
know 68 in puzzle Rush the only other
person to be that high up rather than
Ray is this man right here I mean it
looks like you know some type of like
you know a serious like he looks like a
UFC see fighter or something like he's
about to fight right now this is a
serious Fight Card my guy so the F it
tells it right there pix says a thousand
words and that man is not ready for
anything I know today I don't know how
many people have broken 4,000 puzzles
rating on chess.com we'd probably have
to get a a stat guy on that but that's
that's that's crazy right there it's
funny because this guy makes everybody
else look silly from Super Grand Masters
to anyone else he tends to battle in
these in these formats we do every year
Cy but when he goes up against Ray it's
just everyone I guess a lot of the top
players have their have their Magnus
over the last couple decades and I guess
Demetrius has his Ray just you know it's
just hard to get over the goat sometimes
right but all
right we got chat with us already I'm
going to take a second to give a shout
out because we got a couple minutes here
before the puzzle so down but all right
Kenny what what is your favorite part of
this we've we've already got some people
streaming by the way if you're going to
follow us today follow some of these
some of these streamers in their own
view we see mlay is already getting
warmed up um in some preview preview
screen that candy and I can seen but but
your uh your favorite part of this event
my favorite part of this event is
honestly the how inspired I am to do
more puzzles afterwards I think you see
these guys it's impressive it's so fun
to watch it's a fun to be a part of it
and hopefully at home it inspires you to
actually go do something and try to get
better even if you're doing 10 to 20
more puzzles per day honestly for me
this is one of my favorite parts of the
year because I get inspired again
especially when you see Ray and and boy
do at what they do with less time there
yeah no it it is crazy and there's going
to be a gauntlet of of super impressive
streamers going down today again you
you've seen the list of registered
players I think we're GNA I think we're
going to jump in and check out mlay
we've uh we've got him going right now
looks like he just he just switched to a
Google doc like he's reading the rules
or something
know Min does this too bro he does this
all the time on his real stream he
actually like just
always he's a Taber for real he's he's a
tab he's a tab and uh he's got the timer
up that's what everybody is racing
against if you just tuned in you missed
us preview the format so I'll remind you
one more time it's 30 minutes of solving
three minute puzzle rushes to put up
your best possible scores and then we
rank them and we pair them off and we
get to that second round where it is a
knockout the players are battling
against each other even though we are
not in the puzzle battle mode yet that
part of the puzzles will championship
starts on day two so here's mlay look
closely you can read everybody on his
spreadsheet he's just showing showing
the super high power Tech crushing
things behind the scenes showing his tab
make sure his IP dress up ain't up there
he's an advanced streamer that's not up
there perfect he's good to
go I love it I've uh i' I've got twitch
pulled up as well there are there are a
lot of people here I just opened up the
chess bra stream we've got Eric Rosen
going we've got we've got Benny Bach
we've got check okay hey 11 months
thanks for the sub and aniah shout out
to
you I've got chess bra I've got Bach
I've got bortnik I've got Rosen I've got
Hikaru I've got mlay we've got a lot of
people throwing down here Hikaru already
rocking that almost 7K viewers on on
kick over there eating what looks to be
some french fries hi Caro get those
grease off your fingers I need the best
chest from you today bro what is he
right eating french fries right now for
lunch okay well okay I guess that's fine
cuz I I'm G to diet just because I'm
dieting I mean you should you have to
okay all right we're off I think mlay is
is rolling men for the win here we go
this show is so much hype I agree with
you probably the best part is the if
there's if there's a time of the year to
do this event the first week maybe maybe
the best for the community because it
puts everyone on notice like hey why am
I not solving more puzzles improving my
tactical Vision including my pattern
recognition and awareness this is this
is the time of year and uh here we go
get ready for the dizziness to begin I'm
already dizzy and we just started oh man
you know what's funny I do this every I
don't know how long we've been doing
this maybe it was one of them Puzzle
Battle times of the beginning of the
year that actually just got me into the
mode of doing this every single stream
we always start to stream with a clean
50 meaning we have to do 50 in survival
before we all green it can take three
hours if it if if we don't hit it but we
have to hit it before we do anything
else then we'll do three minute puzzle
Rush yeah every night every night then
we'll do three minute puzzle rush and
five and some Puzzle Battle but it's fun
but we're also solving puzzles so now we
have a culture of us doing this every
day you know so all of us are solving
puzzles a lot but man I'm not touching
I'm 51 in five minute and 49 in three
that's it and that's it's harder to get
crazy bro can I just say I love your
discipline if people are not following
James canny or subscribing to his
channel you're missing out hold your
mouse over the twitch player and go give
twitch twitch.tv/ GM canany a follow and
a sub I really do think you have one of
the most INSP irational Brands out there
you're disciplined to like not start the
stream until you solve 50 puzzles in a
row that's the kind of reason I gave up
I gave up streaming I don't have that
discipline right I got discipline in
other areas but speaking of discipline
we've got we've got an undisciplined
finish here from mlay he's missed a
couple in a row there that's gonna hurt
his best potential time all right KY
let's let's zoom out and do our first
ver I view here of the puzzles World
Championship there are so many throwing
down we're going to we're going to back
up and show you some of those that are
going right now here in a second we are
soon as the the team gets my queue on
that well men going for another run here
you know with the three so we got 30
minutes to get it done so 30 minutes
yeah he's going for we're going to stick
with mlay here before we bring up
everybody U we we can see the bird's
eyes so we'll get it to you everybody
here in a second um but uh but all right
the standings are rolling soon though
will be updated with scores by the way
Christopher U Rasmus Spain some others
we haven't mentioned yet throwing down
here I we're gonna see the best scores
updated throughout this half an hour
it's gonna be epic johnb Jeffrey X
Jeff's there rard Terry is one that
you're not expecting to see up there
also Prav new GM as well yeah RX sadani
I didn't know he was super nice like
that with puzzles I knew he was good but
he's very nice with puzzles apparently
so I got to see that
you know it's funny you mentioned
Jeffrey real quick I think we should
give a shout out to the fact that you
know we did the player profiles to start
with um you know Ray Shay Robson you got
to mention him and then of course we
talked about Demetrus lulos but Jeffrey
Jong is is someone who memory serves me
and I I should have a good memory
because I've hosted this event for the
last several years he's he's made it to
the semis I think every year wow and
then and then lost to either a ray or a
so Jeff Jeffrey is
also or Jus I'm sorry yeah Jus Demetrius
lulos yeah so so yeah he's a guy to
Circle Jeffrey Jong solves himself some
puzzles yeah that's sweet that's I I
actually for some reason just don't
remember I guess he's one of the the
finalists that make it that you like
yeah I remember a few but Jeffrey just
is not doesn't get as much credit there
that's huge to see if Jeffrey's making
it every year Jeffrey is a dark horse
there that nobody's really even paying
attention to unless you actually know
the stats agreed Town population US you
see the scores coming in now we'll get
them updated as they're Happ look at
that Jeffrey Jeong right on that's like
first one top of the
leaderboard we'll uh we'll switch over
we'll give everyone everyone some looks
here in a second and uh make sure that
everyone knows who's who's streaming
let's talk a little bit about the
educational aspect of this you see the
ones that start to slow them down I
think that I think there's a there's a
good pattern okay it's Queen B8 there no
it's not Queen B8 Queen B8 there's
bishop8 and queen back5 oh my
God what a you know those those ones Cy
were there's a retreating move after an
aggressive move are some of the most
counterintuitive puzzles to solve you
know what we say on stream all the time
when we get it wrong or it's a crazy one
we always like hey you know I got
Danny's number I'm gonna call him right
now we got to get this one out of the
system like we always blame it on you
Danny like like everything else in
chess.com when it goes wrong we blame
you so anytime the puzzles have are
weird like that we immediately blame you
for it so you know we got we got that
fix on the back blame Danny there should
be a hashtag I I don't even know why
there why there isn't at this point but
all right let's jump into the bird's
eyee view at this point because then
we'll be able to choose our adventure
and head over to anyone's stream we want
to see and you see there right in the
upper left corner Hans Neeman no point
in dancing around the fact that this
might be his uh I think this is his
first official EV event back that I've
commentated on Hans like everybody was
invited to play in this event and there
you see him throwing down before the
major controversies of 2022 and Beyond
Hans was also one of the top puzzle
solvers we ever had on the site so it'll
be interesting to see what he does today
you've got Ray Shay there in the lower
left you've got mlay and I don't quite
see who is that in the lower right just
being honest oh that's kaspar yeah yeah
right exactly with a c with to see yeah
Casper he's pretty nice with puzzles too
as well as we see 51 there high from
Hans 54 oh that's big Ray have a nice
day of course easy that's a warmup like
yeah 54 and and to imagine that he's had
10 more than that is insane to me like
he's had 19 almost okay 15 more than
that at 69 right I mean that is how that
that must have been one of those runs if
you missed it everybody we talked about
Ray's best run ever of 69 in three
minutes that is that is an insanely
crazy number uh and it's hard to
understand how you can physically pull
that off other than it must have been
one of those lucky runs where the
algorithm just worked out where a
combination of him feeling fresh that
day and having seen maybe a few of the
puzzles before KY I think that's how you
put up a number like that that's and
there he is the goat if you didn't know
now you know Ray Robson is the goat of
puzzles and there is no debating it I
mean he's wanted every single year that
we've had it we've had it Ray won it
that's it where is it oh is Ray there oh
it's over like don't show up every year
has been Ray and have a nice day so
we're gonna see if he's going to do the
same thing this year as well I remember
when spicy caterpillar first came in as
a username um sorry there's no I feel so
old candy whenever I'm doing stuff
there's no ability for me to answer
questions these days without some story
some story of of when somebody was first
accused of cheating or when this first
thing broke the server but in this case
I remember when Ry made the anonymous
spicy caterpillar account he had a he
had a different username and the amount
of accusations I got because puzzle Rush
was so hot and everyone wanted the best
score that there was no world where
whoever the user of spicy caterpillar
was wasn't cheating like the accusations
I got and first of all I'm like that
speed how would you o other than other
than like knowing the puzzle ID in some
way and like working around like a bug
like an actual bug on the server moving
that fast and solving that many puzzles
is just I don't know how you would sheet
that's actually an interesting question
for those expert cheaters out there
correct they like well technically we
got to see them in chat if you're in
chat definitely let us know here that'd
be great we can hey if if you're one of
those guys who currently claims to be
cheating on chef.com and getting away
with it go ahead and post in chat for me
right now can we get your username uh
we'll get you a diamond we'll get you a
free Diamond today there are much less
of those than um than the rumors would
tell you but uh but any we'll get into
that later CNY look at look at Ray
deliberate at number 49
taking his time takes okay Rook take oh
it was wrong dang and you know even when
you at like even if he was at 65 and he
got that wrong he'll be like oh I got it
wrong bro you're at six no one does this
like you're gonna get it wrong at some
point but you love that discipline you
love that I want to get every single one
of them right type mentality I I love
these moments where Ry has clearly not
seen the puzzles before not because that
that is always the case ear on but there
there you would be surprised I think how
how like when he has to really think
through some of these crazy one like
then he gets an advant look how I mean
dude the last move of that puzzle was
King
H3 discover check are you kid yeah Danny
yeah and I say that to him like Danny
fix it it's your fault Danny right but
he did it he did it with no time and so
my point is that's one that is crazy as
it is I would bet Ray has seen that
puzzle before and it's always fun when
he gets positions that you know he
hasn't seen before at the highest level
one that gives a shout out to our team
working super hard we are always trying
to update the database with puzzles
north of the 3,000 rating barrier which
by the way is a pretty difficult thing
to do to to prune puzzles and not allow
for multiple Solutions at that at that
level so shout out shout out to the
whole crew who makes the puzzles Feature
work they don't get enough credit back
in Danny do you know how many is there a
number that you know of how many puzzles
we have on
just.com oh dude it's it's it's in the
hundreds of thousands I don't know that
it's reached a million but maybe it has
well someone ping Roland on slack Roland
our our uh our director of research an
absolute God behind the cheating
algorithm and the puzzles on chess.com
well someone ask Roland how many puzzles
there are shout out to the team I'm I'm
serious I'd actually like to know and I
believe we do have now now north of
30,000 puzzles north of at least like
2,800 if not 3,000 we have drastically
increased that number wow but I don't
know what the concrete number is above
above that threshold okay very nice we
love that we love to see that type of
type of work here because I mean as a
puzzle fan myself chat let's get chat
involved chat hey put your highest
puzzle Rush score maybe three minute
five minute or Survival let's make sure
we put what it is 35 or survival in the
chat what is your highest so you can try
to compare it to some of the greats here
today and hopefully you'll be able to do
the same at some point hey Chad there's
Danny and Chad look at that what you got
chat
I love that 20 look at that 46 4 I'm
giving a diamond to someone who gives me
their my my favorite answer 100 that's
probably the first obvious lie elegant
be Lord I'm gonna I'm gonna guess you're
lying about 100 unless it's survival
mode sorry to call you out about that
elegant be Lord 35 survival 88 62
survival
nice first person who gives me an answer
that makes me smile I'm going to I'm
going to throw out a diamond for today
it's the New Year there you go look at
that it's the new year new diamond come
on diamonds are a puzzle solver's best
friend that's right 43 20s nice job chat
everybody's doing puzzles that's what's
up we doing puzzles everybody we got a
lot of people 69 throwing it out there
for the memes and the giggles for the
memes terrible at chess is one more than
Danny there you go get that guy a
diamond membership ter terrible someone
reach out to terrible chess get his
chess.com username he just got a
three-month Diamond membership terrible
three months big dog wow three
look at
that this is this is this is epic I
assume
55 is the lead we gota we gota we're
going to update his top Rush here in a
second because obviously it's higher
than 54 now he's at 57 will we get 60
come on Ray give me 60 baby come on Ray
60 okay uh King H5 F5 okay yeah we just
gonna follow what Ray says he knows Rook
here Rook down oh 58 not enough time and
that is the highest he's doing this in I
mean that 13 minutes got this done look
at the discipline there that's what
everyone can learn from he takes a
moment obviously he's a he's a person
who can afford some time because he
knows he's not in a rush to make make
the top score but he takes a moment to
look at the answer to the position and I
think that how many of you out there in
chat raise your hand if you're guilty
hit rematch when you know you should
probably hit game reveiew how many of
you hit next puzzle Rush when you know
you should probably go back and see the
red you got guilty come on come on chat
we do this every night every night we go
back and we check every single one there
you are but that's good accountability
chat now I want all of y'all to do your
puzzle rushes right now every you know
right now if you're watching the chat go
up and just do puzzle Rush right now
three minute or five minute tell me what
your new score is beat your high score
today it's happening it's done but it it
really it
it I'm not trying to do you bad Al ALU
but I'm being honest right you've got to
take a moment because even if you're
just establishing one critical mistake
you made in a game from game review
that's how you build and like chess I
don't know if you've seen it chess
justess has a lot of games out there
tens of millions a day just on chess.com
so if you're not taking a moment then
it's just it's hard to really expect
results and I love seeing raised
discipline to see the answer but all
right I also love seeing the bird's eye
view let's back this thing up one more
time like juvenile call me Big Daddy
when you back that thing up right you
you a fine look streamer when you backed
that thing up you call me you call me
Big Daddy when you backed that thing up
okay KY what you doing with it back that
thing
up yes Chad yes of course this is uh how
the lyrics go in fact 100% it is that's
exactly how it goes you a fine looking
streamer When You Back That Thing Up
Hikaru Nakamura is a fine looking
streamer he's got a 55 score I think
it's time to check in with the one and
only Mr Nakamura the man himself have
men have everything else the other half
we don't know yet 55 from Hikaru he's
right behind I mean that's that's very
impressive in fact I think that's number
two actually well I see on the other
screen there I see penguin GM is at 552
but yeah he's a close second he close
second close second I just learned we
can we can we can now zoom into the
audio that these streamers are bringing
us sweet so let's go ahead and uh we'll
take a chill pill here and we'll listen
in to Nakamura and and see what uh see
what he's talking
about wait is that aele can they hear me
and Hikaru at the same
[Music]
time I hope so cuz I'm about to bust out
karaoke
sweet
Devo
Expos there you go can they can they
hear me and hikaro or are we muted to
the to the to the chat
World they can oh okay I was I was I was
debating whether I was going to keep
singing
I no Danny you just sing and dance buddy
no one can hear or
can oh man nothing like chat saying
you're muted after I directly ask can
you hear me right no no you're muted oh
okay yeah yeah no no you're muted keep
going appreciate it Adele by the way I
love Adele can I I am I am an Adele fan
you know I am a Michael Bolton fan to
for my money it does not get any better
than when he sings When a Man Loves a
Woman can we just say that chat yes yay
or nay Chad yeah or nayad was the come
on Chad always
knows all right what do we got we got
Hikaru in a plus 40 perfect run you know
Kenny we talk about the fact that right
right now they're all competing in their
own world reminder chat it's 30 minutes
of put up your best time so that you
don't have to go home but
the the battles that we're going to
throw down at the end of today and
tomorrow we often talk about that 40 and
perfect Mark right that Steve corell's
uh uh you know 40-year-old version we
got the the second sequel coming out 40
in perfect the when you can hit that 40
mark and be perfect that's when you have
real potential for for for a solid rush
we talk about that yeah 100% that 40 is
is a nice Milestone too as well but also
you now know you have to slow down you
have also check how much time do I have
should I Beed it up a little bit also
just says I just heard him say oh pu are
a little bit harder than usual usually
we say yeah they they thrw Danny and
them thre another bat in someone can
tell me what is I should be to I mean if
I'm not top 20 55 i''d be kind of
shocked he did oh great I just glitched
car's like if I'm not top 20 bro you're
number four you're doing fine you're
actually tied for second second he's
like um but by the way the
fact oh it's not I'm actually so happy
because huge score okay I should be in
the top
okay is to update the batch and make it
harder I'm still waiting on on chat or
staff to get back to me on uh how many
puzzles we have total in the database if
someone could reach out to Mr
Roland be nice time for second there
chat as you see up there on the screen
you already have this puzzle just
showing where everyone is man that's
nasty like Ray up there with three more
than a top score even hearu with a 55
like
geez yeah I just I went full I did the
thing you're not supposed to do as a
commentator I went fully only caring
about the chess and people were like no
I want that but then they want
entertainment too but anyway yeah um I
was focused on those last couple puzzles
that hikara was stumped with they got
they got real nasty there in the mid-50s
they do sometimes it's like a a very
difficult puzzle where you have to find
the quiet move for instance that King H3
where Ray was playing in like 58 or
something you play King H3 and like oh
you're winning by a pawn in an end game
like bro this is I always to say I'm
like you
know shut door come on you know what
call Danny right now get him on the
phone right shut the front door with
that pawn up in an end game you know
damn you Danny damn you damn Daniel Dan
all right we've got uh Dan's fall
CH we've got we've got Hikaru on on
Route on route to do the thing that uh
we expect him to do he will qualify of
course for the next round I I'd be
curious I don't know if it's possible
for us to quickly look at the standings
we have 99 people streaming their view
which is a required part of this first
stage in the puzzles World Championship
everyone needs to throw down publicly
everybody stream 99 yeah we've also got
Zoom we've also got play Don't You Worry
everybody but um this part of the the
stage I would love to find out who's on
who's on the cutline production if you
can hear me I'd love to take a look at
the standings and maybe tune in to
someone here we go look at that so we
got bortnik oh Jus is on the cut line 53
that's actually kind of close and it
shows you where we've come KY there's a
lot of great puzzle solvers here oh you
have a mck I mean the other Bortnick
brother higher than his than uh under
there slippery Speer is an underrated
kid FM strong he comes to the stream a
lot at 53 up there beefing Liam Liam the
young Liam three IM Norms young Phenom
54 out of New York very strong very
strong comp here yeah if Jim I mean wow
that's crazy Jims could be knocked
out let's do that let's find someone
who's on the cut line because that gives
us a little bit of a rooting interest
right now the drama if you could find
whoever's ranked 21 I would love that I
want to I want to tune in to the person
who's fighting for their life as we now
are under the 10 minutes remaining Mark
there is only nine plus here remember
that at that Mark only the top 20 will
move on so we're gonna we're going to
try to tune into to someone who's got a
little bit of drama at stake let's head
back to the bird's eye view too in the
meantime if we can do
that let's go we've got Hikaru solving
fans of hikaro know where to find him
right now it's right there kick.com
gmhikaru there he is
there he is Sol check check mate nice SM
there he's on the early
ones
takes there we go hikaro still takes
takes taking we got Jims up there as we
said he's kind of on the cut we know Ray
is uh Ray's safe with a 58 safely number
one right now you know he could just
just stop all right y'all I'm out I'm
about to go get some lunch like I'll be
out I'll see y'all
tomorrow no one is going to okay you you
we could see a 58 it's possible but wow
Ray did first 13 minutes first 13
minutes he's just getting warmed up but
let's go to jimas at the 503 Mark just
for those who don't know he's right on
the cusp he would be in right now but if
someone else Leap Frog him he's
currently ranked 19th the last time I
saw the scoreboard right there so a
great run by bortnik could LeapFrog him
to literally living on the edge only the
top 20 move on to the stage Danny how
hey man he got GL he already got he must
got the bif focals in them boys look at
the
board you can't see anything what what
is the theory behind that I've seen
people do it you know this reminds me of
Larry C shout out to the OG Larry
Christensen Legend on the internet chess
club ICC look at that he's checking the
standings he knows he's on the cut baby
him nervous him nervous right now he's
trying to get in there he said Jess Jim
is with a 3020 Vision that boy got some
serious Vision here my I guess he's not
that nervous taking the time to open up
what he got wrong maybe he thinks it's
just that hard for a couple people to
Leap Frog him with 53 but you got to be
you got to be thinking he's aware that
the game has changed man he he now has a
lot more competition for the argument of
who the second best puzzle solver in the
world is knowing that the the debate of
who's going to beat Ray at this point I
I can't waste my breath on that at this
time like Ray Robson is is bopping yeah
hey hey Robinson big Ray and have a nice
day the man is a is an absolute Legend
he win it every single year Jim was a
competition but right now he's not even
you know in the top 10 he of course
still has a lot of time here but it is
not easy for him as it has been in the
other years as we see this competition
too as well I mean some new names up
there who I don't even know who that is
yose who is that
yose pather p number nine there I have
never seen this name in my knife maybe
it's a username chat anyone know who
that is
yose maybe it's Jose yose how do you say
that Yos I don't know definitely saying
that I'm wrong we see we got josam there
at uh at number 11 he'll be moving on in
the next round online Blitz Legend hey
canny if I told you there are three
grand Masters in the history of
chess.com who have played more than a
100,000 games on our server let that s
in 100,000
games would it shock you to know that
josb is one of them wow yes
100% what 100,000 games have been played
on just.com by
josam let that statistic s in just for a
little bit and there's only
three there's only three you can guess
at the other two they're not as well
known they don't stream they're not
consistently also competing well at
title Tuesday but that's that's that's
pretty bananas um and uh there you go so
ooh actually we need to tune into
bourney cuz guess who just got bumped
from number 20 to 21 the bullet
specialist Alexander bortnik is now is
now on the edge that dude has to get
better or he's going home that's crazy
even say yeah you gotta get you got to
do better than 52 and three minute
puzzle Rush chat think about that for a
second put yourself in that situation
you got to give more than 52 you suck
like that's it you're done like what
this is
crazy so what is he I think he he has to
get to 53 to get back in the top 20 has
to get oh my God this is crazy he's got
four and a half minutes to do
it yeah we definitely absolute bananas
definitely can there it is takes M
check uh takes gotta
take right yeah D2 nice trap the queen
oo
spicy check maybe take the Rook there
there he takes the Rook block takes half
games Rook E6 is nice oh F6 easy takes
Tak oh
F6 what was that last move there that
was wild yeah it was wild3 Queen and
then Rook
G1 hit him H hit him Mak you want to go
Al paccino you just start
screaming check check check Pino when he
just when his acting career became just
pure screaming love that guy yeah that's
great that's great well this a crazy one
again everyone let it sink in this is
not just a puzzle Rush we're following
here this is material Alexander bortnik
would be going home if he doesn't get to
53 he may not have a better chance than
this he's at 50 you got dude you got to
go fast you got three seconds
got he restarted I think yeah bro yeah
that's it he's like I gotta run it
through run it
back man this is crazy nerve-wracking
for those who wonder who are wondering
Alexander bortnik is currently number
number 21 so he's not even in the top 20
there followed by genas K for those who
don't know that's Fredo Perez Panza for
those who don't know that username a
grandmas who's also very strong at Blitz
he will not make the top 20 at this
point so a really really strong list of
people not going to make the top 20
possibly
including the man you're watching right
now unless he put I think it's right now
KY this is this is 53 or go home I think
even chat saying uh there's some also
some updates so there could be some
shakes in the standings is there's 60
for Ray and then 57 for Liam young Liam
Liam does puzzle about every night he's
beating nisy a few times I've seen you
know not consistently obviously but it
is very very uh impressive to see from
Liam as if Liam hit a 57 that's pretty
nasty Ron up there with a 57 as
well yeah Rik with the 57 that's pretty
hot I'm I'm nervous for bortnik I got to
I got to admit there are so many names
here that I don't know as well as some
of the big names whether that's because
they're a top grandmas or a streamer no
offense to those who are less known
everybody is streaming but I I will say
like if I was to give a list of who I
think would make the top 20 bortnik
would be up there and 52 in a in a three
minute rush the game has changed canny
the game has changed hated to Love At
The Underdogs on top and I'm Gonna Shine
into my heart stops right so that's
right you know this is uh amazing to see
the SW oh man he's mad molding there you
can tell lot of emotion here lot of
emotion maybe some Russian um adult
words there as well from bortnik is he
definitely Russian adult you said
Russian adult
words yeah correct correct definit I
don't know why I found that so funny
Russian some Russian adult
words byck definitely definitely which
is understand this is it yeah this is it
dude okay but let's actually remind
everyone of the rules because by the way
I agree with that featured chat comment
it is definitely harder to qualifi this
year it's a ton of fun to see how good
some of these puzzle experts are getting
but I want to remind everybody if you
start a rush before the timer goes out
it counts overtime rules in effect so as
long as the shot is released from your
hand the ball is in the air it counts so
correct meta strategy would probably be
if you're not feeling your ability to
hit 53 if you're bortnik he should quit
that rush and start right before the
time Runs Out in order to give himself
one more chance KY and that's that's
actually critical yeah he needs to be
able to 30 seconds here hold on how much
time he got no you need to start okay he
he has enough time he know he has enough
time but he not going to hit it here
this is it bnck it's now or nothing he
got 50 there he needed two more I mean
how hard is it to get two exactly right
no it's easier to set it down I'm at 49
still trying to touch 50 in three pie
it's hard hard
crazy oh man oh you oh you got 10
seconds he over here looking yo you have
to you got dude you got to start you got
to start your next round five he know he
knows the rules here he goes he's gonna
start one more time stop stop figuring
out the aners there you go get one oh my
God literally started that he literally
started it like what
the freaking buzzer oh my goodness oh my
God by the way speaking of big names who
would not move on unless a huge shakeup
happens Benjamin Bach popular streamer
his best score currently is 50 Bach
would not move
on uh by the way genas K as we said
Fredrico Perez pona just went to 53 I
don't know if that's enough haven't seen
the updated standing yes indeed look at
that number 20 is gangas K canny so he
is in a long but look at Christopher you
living on the edge that's someone we
know who's got a lot of top stuff in him
the young man from
California California Welcome to
California okay we we've got Christopher
you Christopher you at a 503 there
beefy so many big names who just won't
be moving on the chess Queen Alexander
cuk unfortunately Grandmaster cror
mearian not going to be able to move on
to the next
round Rosen rosen's got 45 a good score
for Rosen but not enough to make the top
20 I bet a lot of these guys CNY are
like man 45 doesn't make the top 20 what
has happened to this puzzles world yeah
you know I mean I can understand I saw
and this is like a quick just like a
Overlook of all chess I'm seeing a lot
of the kids that are sharp are doing
puzzle rush and Puzzle Battle all day
and every day it's just a thing that
they're doing a lot of them so I'm
seeing this so I'm like all right cool
what you do you implement you do the
same yeah so to stay on top or to stay
sharp here is doing what they were doing
a lot of times you see Liam up there one
of these uh young kids in the pack 57
top three here it's pretty insane but he
does this every day as
well yeah this is this is crazy bortnik
by the
way he's smartly taking his time but
while he is playing with house money in
terms of the format meaning this Rush
did start before the clock went to zero
so it counts he's not playing with house
money in terms of the three-minute
countdown he now has less than 50
seconds canny he doesn't have perfect in
40 shout out to Steve Carell um I
remember the
days when you could do a movie like 40y
old virgin without getting canceled you
know those were the days those were the
days
guys what you say guys these days okay
got to be careful when you're on a show
with me you know pushing that envelope
you never know right well we got Danny
on our side that's right well he's got
two missed and he's only got it's over
it's over he knows it he misses the
third one he's complaining about the
puzzle I got news for you Alexander it's
not the puzzle bro it's not the puzzle
bro call right the classic title player
blames the puzzle then looks at the
answer and goes oh Danny I was wrong
that was this is ridiculous it's Danny
it's Danny you know this is like when
you break up with your girlfriend it's
not me it's you it's you it's you okay
like you're you're the problem
here it's not me it's you wow yeah we're
gonna we're going to make sure that
there are no active rushes in progress
before we show you the final standings
everybody we are going to miss olander
bortnik and a lot of other great people
in the next round what can you say about
a score of 50 not being Enough by the
way we're we're going to pull this up
I've got the live standing sheet here to
tell you the new universe we are in with
puzzle Rush capabilities with the
community the final score needed to be
in the top 20 was not 52 not 53 but 54
and guess who was on the cut
line who Jeffrey Jong Jeffrey Jong josam
Christopher y for youu Jim yo this crazy
it's a whole new St they all had to 4 oh
my goodness that's crazy that's crazy
yeah it's a whole Everything's changed
besides Ray a nice day Everything Has
Changed yeah we're starting in the
bottom half of the standings there as
you can see Hikaru with a 55 spot wasn't
even in the top 10 how crazy is that
absolutely bananas Jeffrey Jong and jbam
two huge names you know from the
community title Tuesday Christopher U
and then Jims that guy previously was
was always world number two when it came
to puzzles maybe not anymore maybe not
anymore that's scary I mean is in like
it just tells you the competition has
leveled up and it's good to see keeps
you very competitive keeps you sharp
keeps you on your toes cuz it's not
given to you as gemus number two three
four times in a row is now number 15
right now well let's go to the top 10
because this is crazy we were we were we
were focused where we should have been
on the drama of the cutline and bortnik
who we were following did go home but uh
by the way Ray puts up a casual 60 spot
the only one with a six in front of his
Rush score Cy uh your thoughts try not
to to to gush over him too hard yeah
that's a 60 ball there you know you do
60 in survival you hype you know you
Flex that some people in I'm like I got
60 they like oh okay you're nice what's
your three minute you know like the 15
what's race three minutes 60 like that's
you just walk away you just stop talking
60 points in three minutes Kobe got
nothing on Ray Shay Robson Jordan's got
nothing on Ray Robson no one's putting
up 60 points in three minutes man we're
talking we're talking you don't put you
don't put up 60 point that is that is uh
that is a lot of fun and uh well we have
it we have our top 20 KY we have our uh
our our field if you will your thoughts
on what we just saw there maybe a
takeaway we haven't talked about just
yet yeah I think uh it's still some
potential in the others that we haven't
seen for instance like buddy pav and
Liam and even a few others that we
didn't even know was going to make it
this far maybe they put up higher
numbers than that but other than that if
you can if you can hit us to 60 you know
it's all R and have a nice day as
everything shines to him anyway but
we'll see if someone can catch up to him
because this is definitely getting it's
heating up now
so beautiful yeah all right well um
there you go we've had our first round
in the books we'll get previews on the
matchups ahead remember in the next
stage the uh the players are now faced
off against one another as far as the
person you have to get a better score
then to move on to day two of our
puzzles World Championship the action
has just begun thanks for being with us
stay active in the chat Mr KY and I will
be right back with more puzzle action
let's
[Music]
go hey everybody it's Danny here and as
you may know chess.com and chessable are
now one and I'm here to show you how you
can make your chess.com and chessable
one in just a few clicks to start let's
log in and connect our chess.com account
I just scroll right here above the
browser and click log in scroll down and
click continue with chess.com now if
you're already logged into chess.com
it's just going to ask you if you want
to approve that connection I'm going to
say yes sir but after approving it'll
bring you right back to the chessable
homepage now the puzzle connect feature
can be found under Tools and you click
puzzle Connect Now what that does after
you type in your username name is it's
going to pull positions from the games
you played on chess.com create your very
own personalized chessable course and
then quiz you with the positions where
you may have missed the best move and
the more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature at
chessable but if you go to chess.com
link you can get 30 days of pro for
free
[Music]
off
okay
[Music]
I like
birds
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
yeah
it's
[Music]
a
welcome back everyone to the 2024
puzzles World Championship Danny wrench
alongside James canny and bed we have a
thrilling first round the top 20 of 99
streamers moved on and to say if you
were to predict the number coming in
candy of what you would need to get to
we should have played that game what
will be the threshold I mean what would
you have guessed be honest now that you
know it was 54 well I would have
probably guessed 50 52 like not 54 54 is
outrageous you know that's really strong
50 52 like we saw a lot of strong
players even board it you know 52 53
like 54 was the number here which is
crazy never would have thought it it's
crazy I I probably would even guessed
High 40s if I remember correctly a
similar format last year was around High
40s low 50s and so we have definitely
seen the community up their game and uh
it's been it's been a fun year now that
we're here and we know that puzzles
puzzles uh are even harder we saw hikaro
say that on camera the the the
competition is even stiffer Here and Now
we move on to the next round where in
every one of these next stages we will
do 30 minutes once again and the bottom
three will go home every round so from
here it's a bit of a gauntlet knockout
you have to keep solving at a super high
level if 54 was needed when we had 99
and now we're down to the top 20 what's
four is going to be needed to stay in
the top I guess I guess you would say 17
if three people are going home every
time so all right we've got 30 minutes
on the clock we've got one of our
streamers ready to tune into I think
this is panov streaming to us from the
chess bra Channel we we'll zoom into to
him here and uh and get
set shout out to PR taking over the
chess bra Channel I didn't know he was I
didn't know he was a bra yeah he's been
playing bra exactly before he was before
he made GM he was actually consistently
in Long matches against Aman and Eric we
would see this we saw the kind of
evolution of Prav buddy panav as we call
him U grow through the chess bra channel
so it's good to see him over here
yeah he he's he's on the chess bra
Channel he's got his whatever that is
it's like a zoomed out kind of fuzzy
background unless that's just the world
he lives in what if you lived in that
world like constantly an episode of
Friends you know where people are going
between dimensions and like everything
you ever see that where someone is like
is shimmering through an object in like
some Marvel movie I think I think flash
has the ability to do that yeah yeah Str
and those type of things D would be
sweet I would go back and talk to my
grandfather to every day that's what I
would be doing every day all right well
frof is uh is going to be solving
puzzles remember everybody we only have
20 streamers left at this stage you
missed the first one it was thrilling
tons of big names went home because 54
was The Benchmark what will it be now Cy
predictions I'm going to guess to move
on to the next
round it has to be
55 get one better okay yeah yeah and I
was saying 54 so I'll say 54 you say 55
so we one off there so we'll be
different there yeah I was G to say the
same because I mean if they're doing cut
off yeah yeah 54 what's interesting is a
tiebreak question I actually don't know
I think I'm going to ask the the team on
slack here because what happens if
you've got five or six people all with
the same score and three are going home
what is the
tiebreaker that's an interesting
question we'll find out we'll find out
next time right now we've got pron off
solving puzzles going crazy finding all
L Queen C6 looked great there he was
correct Queen C6 I guess he's move uh
but I mean he didn't have to play that
that was a strange one he couldn't move
the way Queen E8 Rook down I in Queen E8
o
crazy Bishop
G3 there it
is okay we got we got my my staff is is
listening closely here we've got the
tiebreaker is the best streak you had so
how many puzzles you solved straight so
if you come down to it what's tiebreaker
number two like honestly I'm curious
what happens if both sides have a
40 40 perf here's what I want to know
when do we get to Rambo like at what
stage in in the tiebreaker process are
we playing rock paper scissors that's
what I want to
know that's great that's actually a
great question in fact that we need to
figure out because it is possible okay
this is great the article's got all the
information everyone needs I did read
the article but it was last week and
that information escaped my brain so we
have a tier system it starts with
highest streak then it's the highest
puzzle solved which is our database can
clarify quickly and if we're still tied
it's average time per puzzle if we get
to that stage someone is busting out
their manual calculator at home and
punching punching it into a show that
will forever then be sponsored by Texas
Instruments shout out to the calculator
right there that's great man but is
possible guys it is very possible down
to the average second per puzzle
like by the way fun
fact the last last year's score that was
good enough to move on this year year it
took it took 54 last year I was right it
was high 40s it was 49 it was 49 that's
crazy and i' be doing 49ers all the time
I would have made it in like this year
just H50 like not making it the the
community the world has gotten five
puzzles better on average in this year's
puzzle World Championship that's the b y
yep so we got that's just at home chat
we got more work to do chat we have more
work to do Chad we just got to keep
working every day we got more work to do
there you go you got your next challenge
you got to get 50 you got to get to 50
in 3 minutes from now on that's that's
the next Cy challenge that's gross I'm
doing 49s all the time that's gross 50s
50 has to be an average when you start
averaging 50 that's
scary seriously that's scary all right
we've got 6,000 of you with us on Twitch
4,000 of you with us on YouTube shout
out to everyone we asked earlier what
your best three minute score was most of
you gave answers the person who trolled
me got a diamond membership that's how
we do things here in the New Year all
right let's talk about oh look at that
perfect at 40 cany I say this is The
Benchmark you got to hit you got to be
perfect at 40 because this is where
you're going to miss a couple you got to
have some insurance you know you got to
have a couple of whatever you want to
call
it too with extra 40 you also need to
have the time because you can had a
perfect 40 but have a minute left and
you only get maybe 45 maybe 46 so you
have perfect 40 and an extra maybe
minute 32 minutes on yeah I I think
that's what we talked about last year
it's got to be 40 with 90 seconds oh
really okay 40 with 90 yeah yeah yeah I
think I think and by the way he's about
to hit
50 with okay slowing down this is what
happens I do the same thing it sucks cuz
maybe H3 yeah it's probably H3 something
stupid oh my goodness here we go
something crazy hurts you Rook H1 no
doesn't work F3 uh didn't get
it oh tough tough run yeah huge run for
buddy buddy right there the nickname
he's earned there over at the chess bra
Community buddy panov is uh I can't tell
if that was like demeaning because he
was like young or I don't know what the
buddy was you know because some people
just say buddy like you know like like
my my 15-year-old hates being called
buddy like what's up sport what's up
buddy what's up champ like teenage boys
aren't a big fan of that you know or if
it's or is it like a Canadian thing like
hey buddy like you want to go out for a
rip hey hey boyo you know go out for a
rip yeah I think it's yeah somebody in
ch say Canadian thing and Eric says it a
lot so I know Eric hey buddy hey buddy
you know that's Eric so Eric's very
buddy you know so he called him a lot he
called that a lot and I think that's
just what it was just great so no no uh
no age boy offense needed there and look
at this guy soling we're gonna we're
going to stick with pron off maybe maybe
we'll actually come back and check in
with with our buddy here and now that
the scores are really rolling in you see
Jeffrey Jong number one there at 55
let's head over to the bird's eye view
and check out check out our uh our
menu what evening is Ray even here he
just go get l oh here he is he's number
four because he really could just go
like do whatever I like you know but
well he at 58 yeah but he to get through
this run too I guess as well so you have
to get through each one okay I got to
put up a 58 every run got to put up a 58
we've got we've got our options our
flavor to pick from why don't you choose
the uh the next part of this beautiful
program we haven't seen Rak let's go to
ROK and then maybe josam after that okay
and also Liam we got Liam too man this
everybody's here so that's a hard one
but let's let's check in on ROK Rono
doesn't get as much love uh these days
but also more about
um him just I didn't I was it was a
surprise to even see him in this event
so the CM is he's pretty cool pretty
strong player obviously as we know um so
I didn't know his puzzle game was really
nice too as well yeah well these guys
are strong they're fast they grew up
online it's going online can't take it
down from there man it's going to be
there all day this these guys grew up
online and they are ready look at the
heat look at the speed he's bringing by
the way criticism for Rono stream I
can't see his current number that yeah
what number is he at correct yeah
feedback for Round unle by the way we
got a YouTube streamer that Community is
growing I'm going to give a little shout
out to the community if you didn't know
now you know chess.com expanded its Tech
recently to give embed to our YouTube
streamers so if you're out there you
have a YouTube channel or if uh you just
want to tell your friends about this
we're now expanding our ability to
support and grow the community with some
YouTube support so it's not just twitch
exclusive and uh go to youtube.com right
now give rxx sadani a follow or whatever
they call it on YouTube some sort of
subscribe you know what you know oh he's
on YouTube streamer okay YouTube
youtubeer YouTube streamer there you go
good see there you go so the YouTube
Community will be growing and uh and the
streamers on YouTube we saw Anish giri
streaming the title Tuesday against
everyone else's you know wishes
basically Anish you know no one wants to
see that but he's streaming anyway um
but uh
but but you see Anish doesn't throw down
here I think a lot of the top Grand
Masters gave up on it Hikaru loves the
content but I'm I'm going to give a call
out I don't think a lot of these guys
like their ego being hurt by the fact
that a bunch of non-title players are
are are smoking them at puzzle solving
I'm G be real yeah I guess it hurts the
ego a little bit maybe it hurts little
hurts the ego just a teeny bit ego I'm
2800 bro you can't do this to me you
know like that's right and then Ray
Robson is like not only beating them
like what he's doing isn't isn't legal
and of the 50 states I mean like what
Ray's doing is is is violating you know
some of these some of these guys egos
pretty hard so
um but
uh but yeah all right we've got the
scores coming
in here in the top
20 you see a lot of people throwing down
there we've got the 11th through 20th
right in front of you remember the
bottom three will go home in this half
an hour let's back up to our bird's eye
view when we get a second as much as I
love ROK we gave him the love I'm not a
huge fan of his stream I can't see the
clock I can't see the puzzle Sol timer
the nothing yeah feedback for R camera
looks good it looks clean I like the box
look very clean you know you know this
just turned into America's Got streaming
talent and you and I are
criticizing the uh yeah yeah that funny
yeah all right we're gonna we're gonna
leave ROK right where he is and head
back over to the bird's eyee view we
still got buddy prawn off there on the
upper left 40 is not going to cut it
here in round two buddy he's going to
have to pick it
up yeah 58 was I saw 5'8 there maybe
they just changed it back to 54 but I
don't know JN I think we got to go to
that lower right KY we got Jeffrey X
that's Jeffrey John I I shout it out for
those who've been with us in the
beginning that Jeffrey is an underrated
puzzle solver when you think of the big
names of Jims and Ray Jeffrey has made
it to the semi-finals I believe all four
years but at least the last couple
before this year so and look at him
right now he's he's he was almost
perfect at 50 his top Rush currently 55
he's killing it canny Chef Jeff is a
experienced cook I mean as we know he
just uh he does his thing he can cook it
however you like it or however you don't
like it it's going to get served that's
Chef Jeff for you every single time so
of course um he gets it done bro every
year he's been doing it and you see him
in the puzzles you also see him in the
high Lev events to as well doing very
very well so uh he's been around a long
time doing this also 2700 I think former
I don't know if he's still 27 but 27 OTB
so the man is an absolute beast and a
legend dropping a 55 today can I get a
shout out to that featured chat comment
about how many puzzles stockfish would
solve I think I think initially when you
read it you wonder if they're trolling
but I think that's actually a
fascinating question because obviously
the computers know the answer but I
would love to see if we could build a
model where where stockfish is solving
in real time that' be because there's
you know there there are question like
obviously it just comes down to the CPU
like is it like is it Cloud supported is
it local hardware at some point there is
a depth and a pure power issue when it
comes to how quickly engines will solve
things and and arrive at the best answer
um it's one of the difficult things we
deal with cheating at times because
sometimes Advanced cheaters think if
they solve things with a slightly weaker
engine lower depth whatever it's harder
to catch twist ending it's not we're all
over that in the algorithm um but the
point is engines do evaluate things
differently based on the strength right
and I'm actually that's actually I don't
know that's an interesting question to
me I don't know how many how many how
many stock solves that would be solving
computer Championship oh yeah that's the
next up look y'all heard that you know
let's get it in the work come on chesc
we can do that that'll be sweet I'll be
love to see it and then you get to uh
just wow at it all at it and try to use
it to our own
benefit agreed Town population us all
right Jeff's at that Mark we talk about
perfect for 40 and more than 90 seconds
remaining this has the makings of a of a
good rush let's stay right here with Mr
Jong okay see what he can do takes his
beautiful oh that was strong wow I
wonder what it was Queen F5 check wow
Queen E6 or Knight F6 what's going on
you got Queen G5 it was Queen G5 first
was couldn't well the Knight couldn't
block as the D2 Bishop hang and I think
that's what he missed Queen G5 first and
then and then Queen F4
what this one takes Knight F3 yeah it's
got to be and then check with the queen
and then work down there it is nasty
heat takes takes yeah yeah hitting
before we
splitting hitting before we splitting
yeah it's always in order it was I saw
this puzzle earlier for someone I don't
remember who oh this one
um that's nice
okay take take push oh yeah my got
nice G
was it push bro it was G5 oh my goodness
G5 yeah because you have to push in
unbelievable mittens would you have
solved that G5 mittens oh so cute and
then they then Eat You Alive just
waiting watching yeah please for those
who don't know this is the mittens we're
currently calling Chucky mittens around
I'm going to get a quick zoom in here
this is um this is a mittens that came
out with a little bit extra red a little
disturbing this is angry mittens yeah
you know you sleep there Dan or like you
know particular mittens is for me we're
gonna we're GNA give it a big a big
closeup here we're g throw it out there
this you can get your own mittens at the
chess.com merch store they're hot I
think we sold out but we're getting more
um but this is deranged mittens this is
Chucky mittens this mittens gives me
nightmares um wow and just got right
there watching judging
okay man all right chant be careful out
here it is be careful be careful be
careful look at that he's he's seen that
one before there's no way Jeff hadn't
hadn't seen that before there you go
that was a look at this look at this oh
the Rooks the Rooks the Rooks cooking on
the second rank in awkward
fashion look at that sequence Chef Jeff
cooking shake and him let him Rook chat
let him Rook let him Rook it's Rook D1
and then
wow this is where you make those Star
Wars sounds
right check check check there it is
there it is give it to
him is definitely Str
[Music]
one those are the hardest ones to solve
you know when you're looking for mate
you're looking for some pattern and it
doesn't exist you're just winning the
exchange
like come on man get Danny on the phone
get Danny on the phone where's blame
Danny
um thanks
thanks look at it he's perfect at 45 but
this is not his best work yeah you're
right you would almost throw in the
towel if he was actually competing to
stay alive he'd probably throw in the
towel because this is this is I mean
he's got 55 I assume that's going to be
enough but we should we should head back
to the bird's ey view when we can maybe
head another direction as Chef Jeff
Cooks
here I think that's a great like uh way
to plan and strategize if you are aware
of where you need to be at that like you
know that 90 minute part when you at 40
just knows you can probably even slow
down a little bit may not slow down but
save your energy you know save exactly
exactly I think I mean because it is
it's a grueling contest like the best
puzzle solvers in the world is where
we're at this is the puzzles World
Championship welcome in everybody and uh
PE do boys ever grow out of saying
PE like using sound effect you ever just
use sound effects when you're doing
stuff around the house like oh 100%
100% exactly all kind of stuff this is
making all the time oh
man r ray hitting the 58 is that the is
that the penguin gang up there that's
penguin GM let's go check out Andrew
tang tang gang yeah Mr tabs himself in
fact if you go to there I don't know I
think now it's a me thing look at them
tab look at his tabs bro oh my goodness
look at the tabs that's the first thing
I just want yall to notice is he got a
command for it where everything is yeah
I know he obviously must have some
incredible CPU power because that is
like you know your computer freezes up
at that point you know chrome chrome has
to develop custom experiences for people
like this I don't know if that is Chrome
but um yeah tang tang one of the fastest
like I don't know I don't know how we
measure actions per minute in chess
right the the common kind of Esports
sort of mouse speed term
um so um but yeah Tang Tang's actions
per minute from a chess perspective have
got to be some of the best in the world
like maybe top yeah absolutely
especially when it comes to like hyper
bullet and even the uh Ultra bullet
stuff which is 15 second which is crazy
I mean he's just you see him sore all
the time and be even the top players in
this he's always a top three when you
about fastes in these hyper bullet
formats or anything very very fast
penguin GM is there Andrew tank it's
crazy no he really is and and we know he
loves himself some other games I don't
know that he would ever consider other
Esports competition you know um he he
loves himself some Clash Royale does
some other things but shout out to the
Esports industry which died last year
along with my grandma you know that that
that went away and no one even talked
about the Esports industry struggling
right now but uh you know it's it's
tough it's tough out there to be an
esport but chess is the original OG
esport that's exactly right and even I
think shoot uh he was the first signed
wasn't he see Cloud9 second signed hiar
was first that's right maybe that's
right hiar was first I don't even know I
think Caro or maybe the the bz sisters
but somebody was signed he was the top
three though when Esports start signing
chess players he was up there Cloud
n yeah
yeah well we've got 40 in perfect and 90
seconds can he continue to do it you
know what you see who's at the top up
there Philippians 46 I think that is uh
what's the kid uh T not uh Andy other
Andrew Andy
Woodward Andy Woodward I think is what
CH says which he's going crazy 58 as a
they call I've never heard Andrew called
Andy you heard it yeah Andy Woodward
Andy Woodward yes Rich chat is Right
nice tabs yeah he got a nasty tab game
that that was that was nasty but he
figured it out even though he's missed
two that was hard to decide which one to
take oh that was nice okay check Bishop
G B
G yeah I don't know actually no Bishop
F5 first no it was Bishop the same oh
and then G6 Bishop Bishop F5 G6 yeah
take and then Queen D7 heck what an
absolute Monster by the way he's got 56
though right now we're looking at 11
through 20 I don't know where 56 puts
him we see Christopher U 54 what was our
predictions we said we would need 55 to
stay alive and I said 5 you said
55 I said 54 you
said who is Phillip pien 546 that's a CH
saying that's a chat saying that's Andy
Andy Woodward the kid oh Andy Woodward
yeah the that's that's Andy woodwood
that's that's the
kid we should check that kid out if we
can get that stream up find that's
bananas Andy Woodward the the the kid
who made a name for himself in the game
at least as far as I'm concerned last
year in the proess league he uh he was
pulling upsets and shocking the world
but Andy Woodward is super talented
youngster and that is wild super strong
strong 58 yeah only Ray did that and now
it looks like Hans as well wow three of
them boys up there 58 woo this going to
be a very spicy final this is going to
be very very good I mean I I believe Ray
is obviously the favorite still but
these 358 up here like whoa if Andy
Woodward somehow look we got 358s but if
Andy Woodward the young man I think he's
probably 15 years of age now 15 years of
age um if he is
indeed uh making it to the finals
against Ray what an interesting new new
Challenger enters the arena a new foe
has
arrived exactly a wild Andy has appeared
like what the heck nean also on fire
there got to give a shout out to that
Hans nean with
58 an an incredible puzzle solver for
those who don't know and uh look at that
windmill tactics windmill or go home I
like to
say windmill or go home with there
nothing else to
do oh look at this king king B King a
what there was King A8 oh my God what
a that's deeski page uh
291 dude that is that first of all I
don't think anything highlights a donkey
like having to play King A8 there the
horse is the worst piece when it comes
to stopping the pass Pawn but that was
an interesting move for
sure can we can we get a bird's eyee
view I mean okay let let's let let's let
Tang finish this Rush here because this
looks like yeah could be one of his best
and then we're going to go check out
young Andy Woodward blowing Minds right
there currently at number one over spicy
caterpillar and Hans Neeman who both
also have 58s
oh found it very nice 55 he won
away oh he got time to do it Knight
takes
D4 uh he missed it okay I mean did the
same 55 not bad I don't know that he
knows 56 is safe if you're if you're at
the Tang gang maybe someone in his chat
can let him know uh but
uh but we've got Andy Woodward in the
lower right not a bad looking stream to
throws himself in the in the pink
box right in the corner he know what he
doing he watched a few streams the young
nobody nobody puts baby in a corner I
was thrown into a pink box in a corner
one day but that's a different story
that's a this a Family Channel Danny
don't even tell we are not
going that let's bring up the little the
little box there and uh see what's going
on with Mr Woodward who's got his stream
alerts live a lot of people hitting that
follow button for the young man shout
out to everybody's future chess
streaming
career the uh the chess streamers of
tomorrow you don't even know their name
yet but they're out there they're out
there they're coming if you build it
they will come they are they are they
are on the way they are on the
way
laughing people I don't know that chat's
loving it we're having a good time hey
it bro I you know I learned something I
learned something in life oh man you
know it's it's uh it's not necessarily
possible to offend but it is possible to
get offended I'm just kidding you can't
say anything but you know we're having a
good time and if I offended you I
apologize um but uh all right here we've
got it we've got the kid the kid is at
36 with a minute 56 to go yeah
37 looking good he's trying to figure
out what to
do
see he's not talking a lot I mean we can
listen in I don't know if we want to
find some of our most talkative
streamers but I want to see what this
kid is capable of I'll be honest this is
serious business for these guys and I
don't think that anybody even Hikaru Mr
Mr takes takes takes draw some arrows
himself is uh is I don't think he's
talking a lot but we we'll go to Hikaru
next because we just saw him scream
after getting it I know I saw that he
was Ming at something anybody who's
watching Hikaru over a kick there's a
lot of you he's got 7,500 of you um but
uh but
yeah but
yeah look at this he's 50 imp perfect
what and who is this kid yeah with a
going crazy can I get a stat check on
how old Andy Woodward is he been going
crazy 52 All
Greens everybody go hit that follow
button I see a lot of you are doing it
but uh how old is he again he locked
in hey Ray a new foe has entered the
arena right a new foe has entered the
arena big
Ray what is the answer to this I have no
idea but he's oh my God que that's so
stupid it's a stupid one like you have
to win later
yeah love how you call us 56 with 15
seconds to go oh my goodness
Castle come make the move 59 59 get 59
get 59 59
it9 get off me says the kid off dude go
and brush your shoulder off youngster oh
my God Young fella swinging he's
swinging like Ray
Robson got to 6 but damn is the only way
you describe that he was like I got a
ray gun for Ray watch this dear God now
now somebody needs to tell the kid to
take a break and save it because I want
him to be fresh and funky when it comes
to the head-to-head matchups he'll have
to throw down with later on in today's
show if you're just tuning in where the
bleep have you been it's the puzzles
World Championship on chess.com everyone
is solving puzzle rushes and everybody
you see is actually streaming so if you
want to go check them out their own view
you
can
um but uh but yeah everyone is streaming
let's head back to our bird's eye view
Andy Woodward we now officially know has
arrived if you know you don't know now
you know he's currently number one at 59
what a freaking monster there you see it
hikaro Nakamura and Hans nean side by
side not something you maybe thought
you'd see today but that's what it is
Hans is checking out the score and uh
seeing where he sits having some good
puzzles today I say we check out Hikaru
because well well it looks like he's
going to make it that cut line I
predicted 55 KY predicted
54 he's at 56 KY 56 but
uh where does that put him at okay up
there and like to top okay top T there
yeah currently we're wrong 52 is 52 is
moving on 52 yeah
interesting
bet very doable how much time minute
50 yeah by the way I was wrong I assumed
Andy must have turned 15 at this point
but Andy Woodward is still only 14 years
old I think that's how old he was during
the PCL last year so maybe maybe he's
got a February March birthday maybe he
found a time machine I don't know right
right hopefully both he's got he's got
something keeping him young and I'm
going to stop right there because is the
line I might get canceled on if I keep
going so we're not going to do that he's
he's he is he is still very young and he
is solving puzzles like crazy that is
Andy Woodward and uh he's crushing it
and right now we've got Hikaru at a 56
spot you can go follow him on Kick if
you're into that kind of thing and we'll
see if hikaro can put up a great run
here he's still perfect right now decent
amount of time left yeah see it looks
like a minute in some change there not
sure how much his uh clock is kind of
small there but he's had a great uh he
had a great score in fact so far 56 at
35 and counting seems like he's slowing
down a little bit which is
understandable it's a little
fatigue take take take take take take
take take come on here Caro take take
take easy would Shield he's safe 52 is
wait no no wait I forgot we should this
this is uh this is a good catch for me
so actually
the bottom three are going home in every
round so I apologize for that we need to
get some sort of like red marker or
something on the screen to remind
everybody the cut off line because I
forgot right there looking at it the top
20 are the ones who made it everybody if
you just get tuning in top 20 made it
from the earlier round this is round two
so there you have it those bottom three
scores all with a 52 would go home if
the clock ends and they don't start
another rush so let's let's find one of
those streamers
production if you don't mind who is that
we got to get somebody who's living on
the edge and see the drama in real
time I'm
not he car was in okay that's it time's
up time's up let's see who those last
people
are time is
up wow who is Philippians what's up
chassie you that that is Andy
Woodward correct our pan I see you yeah
that's that's nutty wonderful time is
safe some of the names you know Jeffrey
Jeong is safe Christopher U is safe
we're going to pull up one of these one
of these guys who uh I apologize at this
point chess.com has has a few million
members if you didn't know and I don't
know everyone's username um so I don't
know who those bottom three are we're
going to find out we're GNA we're going
to tune into one of
them yeah we're gonna see who those are
johnan with 56 Caro 56
yeah even shoot um Raiden touch a 59
here Andy Woodward warming up warming up
got a few more of these left these 30
minute rounds wow wow okay we've got a
few people on the cut line let's go to
any one of them because they're all in
the same boat they okay actually looks
like looks like mrava just ended there
so he's out let's go to ants aa75
whatever that username is I can't even
see it let's let's bring that baby up
this is his last run it looks like last
run not sure who this is at all in fact
anyone know
name let's yeah we don't even know but
it's 53 or go home for this community
streamer and um and we will see what he
can do he is still perfect as of this
moment but I'll be honest the speed
worries me but that that's what happens
man it gets hard right you get nervous
and and you just this is so difficult
with the pressure
100% oh that's Anthony Anthony okay I
know
him yeah the pressure build builds up
you realize this my last run here this
could be it I just got to work I just
got to breathe through it we got to work
a minute 30 with 36 you gotta push just
do it yeah yeah I'm nervous I'm nervous
for the for the for the kid the player
whoever whoever this human being is I'm
nervous for them you got to work it
Diggity nope don't
mistake shout out to pitch perfect one
of the most underrated movies of all
time and mate check did you even get
what I what
I Fitz perfect one of the greatest
movies of all oh man I I said No Diggity
never mind I was just pushing the
envelope yeah you got to bag it up and
he's gonna have to keep bagging these
puzzles with no mistakes cuz he's not in
a spot where he can miss he's playing
the he's playing the ultra accurate card
KY where he's like all right I'm I just
can't mess up right I got to get every
single puzzle from
here ah it's your boy get
Wisconsin sorry that's what I do when
there's kids around instead of dropping
F bombs I drop sh Wisconsin oh Shaban
because if anyone doesn't know how
inappropriate it is to reference Shaban
Wisconsin unnecessarily then you haven't
done your homework you got to do some
homework Chad we do have internet okay
all of you watching should have
internet what is this what is this he
taking his time 49 oh okay it makes
sense you have to take a time here
Knight F4 seems good but I don't see the
followup Knight F4 takes Queen F4 Bishop
G2 and then what ah he's stuck I
understand amazing dang dang 20 seconds
you gotta move bro you gotta move KN C3
KN C3 Knight C3 Knight C3 and he's gone
he is absolutely gone he has left the
building he has left the building he
just just completely collapsed broke the
computer
screen what whatever he did right he
went he went full full Magnus there
screen went to Black there right he went
I'm out like that was you know what I'm
not making it and just punch I'm making
it I'm not streaming anymore you know um
I'll I'll rage off camera which is the
appropriate way to rage if you're ever
going to do it right you don't need that
kind of attention don't do it kids it's
not good for you oh man you know what is
good for you
candy what is solving puzzles ah it's
good for the brain they say puzzle a day
keeps the doctor away I heard
that yeah I heard that before puzzles
puzzles a day what did you say a puzzle
a day keeps the uh keeps the doctor away
keeps the blunders keeps the doctor away
it's good for your brain and let's
remind everybody that this has been
puzzle week and it's still running
January 8 through 12th there are
Community prizes lots of motivation to
stream you can submit your best puzzle
survival or puzzle Rush score via the
green ponds Community Twitter if you
haven't hit the follow button for the
green ponds we're building out a
different brand on social to make sure
that you know where to stay in touch if
you are an active Community member
whether it's prizes whether it's games
versus the world like I'm playing right
now fun weird stuff we do for the
community comes at you via the green
pawns account on Twitter and you can win
Diamond memberships this week if you
enter with the command puzzle challenge
by submitting your best scores so there
you go make it happen we're going to
keep making it happen here as the
puzzles World Championship rolls on and
uh three more players have gone home
we're going to be back as we move on to
the next round once again the bottom
three will be going home don't go
anywhere it's more from the 2024 puzzles
World Championship when we
[Music]
return
confusing
one yeah yeah this one is a bit
difficult I thought that you didn't it
for a second good
job so I'm going to show you some
puzzles you're going to have 10 seconds
to look at the tablet and then I'm going
to take tablet away and you're going to
have to give me the solution okay you
ready sure all right Ming five white
move
okay you got it all right yeah Queen G6
kn6 Bishop G7 L H7 very nice very nice
very nice good
start
okay queen6 Queen D6 knight7 Bishop f8
Knight D5 no wait
where's if you go Knight D7 I go King h8
Bishop f f Bishop
H5 yeah that's that's not working
out okay Queen G6 has to be the right
first move
yes um oh Bishop kn6 bishop7 Rook s
that's right yes very
good
okay so it's green text G6 FG Knight E7
check King H7 or King h8 bishop f8 and
then
Bishop H3
H5
uh wait Bishop H5 be play yeah not
Bishop H3 Bishop H5 Knight G5 King h8
and then Knight T G6 is that five uh so
you said Queen takes G6 F takes G6
Knight Knight E7 okay we have Knight F6
here oh Knight F6 Knight F6 King h8 oh
then Bishop f8 yes Bishop
G7 King G
and wait but Knight E7 is not checkm
let's see um knight7 King H7 Bishop
f8 Bishop H5 Bishop H5 Knight G5 wait do
I have a knight on G3 H F3 you do have a
knight on F3 so Knight G5 check King h8
Knight G6 so what if I go King h8 first
instead of King H7 Bishop F Bishop f8
oh Bishop H5 then n G6 H7
I pick up night
okay confusing
one yeah yeah this one is a bit
difficult I thought that you didn't it
for a second good
job so I'm going to show you some
puzzles you're going to have 10 seconds
to look at the tablet and then I'm going
to take tablet away and you're going to
have to give me the solution okay you
ready sure all right m in five white
move okay you got it all right yeah when
six Knight F6 Bishop G7 L H7 very nice
very nice very nice good start
okay queen6 Queen G6 Knight E7 Bishop F
Knight D5 no wait
where's if you go Knight D7 I go King
h8 Bishop f f Bishop
H5 yeah that's that's not working
out okay Queen G6 has to be the right
first move
yes um oh Bishop knight6 bishop7 R
that's right yes very
good okay
so it's Queen takes G6 FG Knight E7
check King H7 or King h8 bishop f8 and
then Bishop H3 or
H5
uh wait Bishop H5 must be play yeah not
Bishop H3 Bishop H5 Knight G5 King h8
and then Knight takes G6 is that five
move uh so you said Queen takes G6 F
takes G6 Knight Knight E7 okay we have
Knight F6 here oh Knight F6 Knight F6
King h8 oh then Bishop f8 yes Bishop
G7 and R7 wait but Knight E7 is not
checkm let's see um knight7 King H7
Bishop
f8 Bishop H5 Bishop H5 Knight G5 wait do
I have a knight on G3 H F3 you do have a
knight on so knight5 check King h8
Knight G6 so what if I go King h8 first
instead of King H7 Bishop f8 Bishop f8
oh then Bishop H5 then n6 s and I pick
up the night okay
[Music]
yeah
back
[Music]
d
we are back konov will be back in a
second I think cuz that's an empty chair
KY you can't solve puzzles with an empty
chair you actually can Danny you can do
it with your phone because you can do
that on the app you can oh my God that
was like a I didn't even set you up for
that that just tells you you know just a
pro how how many puzzles you're solving
on the phone these days are you a are
you a potty Puzzler are you solving
puzzles on the potty be honest you know
what hey man I've having a lot of
protein I ain't going to lie so I have a
lot of focusing to do in fact to say the
least
so I probably not but Chad what about
you Chad what about you guys you've got
you've got a lot of ways to solve
puzzles on chess.com that is the truth
and these guys have been solving a lot
of puzzles let's check out the standings
where we sit after round two if you're
just tuning in we had 99 that is a
number that actually showed up and
streamed the first round only the top 20
moved on from here on out the bottom
three will go home with every half an
hour and that man at the top is a young
man 14 years of age Andy Woodward
International master was better than Ray
Robson I I don't know that I ever
thought those words would come out of my
mouth here ky uh yeah Ray is that's
going to be an angry Ray but also if I'm
if I'm Andy here I'm just going to do
more of the same be fearless and play my
best puzzles that I can play and try to
really get a shot at the title here and
try to take down big Ray and have a nice
day as he's won this thing every year
boy with that be amazing that would not
be the storyline anyone saw coming
especially cuz it's a prodigy storyline
there's no debating it it's a
14-year-old kid who's balling out let's
move to the uh the bottom half of the
standings there you see the top 10
before you Hikaru and josam were just
inside of it oh there you go you've got
josam actually in in 11th place Min lay
and Jeffrey Jong that's wonderful time
for those who don't speak chess.com
username that's wonderful time as mlay
Christopher U and then the bottom three
there I I I'm I'm not going to lie I I I
I don't know who those players are but
we do know that
aa175 turned off his camera real quick
after he knew he wasn't moving on can he
yeah maybe he turned it off or punched
it whatever it was it was gone it was
very fast he got up out of there and
understood I just didn't make it but
definitely an honor to be of course
where he was and to make it that far
anyway as a 99 participants were before
him so pretty nice uh to make it to
where he was but was not able to finish
the last three are
eliminated everyone who made the top 20
took home a couple hundred bucks cash
we'll remind you of the total prize fund
and how that breaks down later on in the
show but guess what it's time for round
three in a puzzle solvers will gather
let's go the universe is at stake why is
it the universe is always at stake like
you don't have to put the universe at
stake Universe bro kids out there man
like come on talking about the universe
they got kid I'm saying like every movie
the universe is at stake like why is
that why you know um everybody just relx
shout out to
chat we got 6K of you plus on Twitch we
got about 3,500 of you on YouTube We're
streaming to some other platforms we
shout out those too and we know we see
you in chat thanks for being with us PR
off the good buddy for the chess bra
channel is underway
let's go PR off and trying to uh really
just come back and get somewhere
probably like to solidify somewhere in
the middle I think he was towards the
bottom somewhere in there but yeah uh
yeah you yes you know just try to pick
it up that's all you can do easier said
than done is this is their third time
doing this today so you know not that
you're getting fresher as the day goes
on and as many puzzles as you get you do
start to fatigue like at any level you
will fatigue a little bit somewhere even
with Ray I mean he hit 60 then he hit 58
I call that fatigue that's crazy but
like 58 was his fatigue there as uh as
um Andy was able to beat him 59 you're
right and and for those who just tuned
in to make it to the top 20 with 99
people you had to get a
54 in this last round we predicted what
it would take to move on it took a 53 so
you and I were both wrong Cy I thought
it I thought it would take a 55 in the
top 20 but the reason I think it was
even lower than the adrenaline hyped
first round out of the gate is cuz I
think there is a little bit of fatigue
right we see some of the players at the
top separating themselves a little bit
but I think for the most part the puzzle
the puzzle grind is on here in the third
round it really it is really grueling
and I always challenge you know chat
especially too as well is just try to
try to sit at home like three or five
minute puzzle rush and sit there 30
minutes an hour of just going back and
back puzzle Rush After puzzle Rush each
time see what your score is does it go
up does it go down but of course you do
get a lot of puzzles in the day
especially if you add it up all the runs
you've done you've done you know
hundreds of puzzles which is very very
uh vital to your chess Improvement so I
think it's pretty fire but I'll admit I
was like like everybody else in late
2018 when puzzle Rush came out I was a
full puzzle Rush addict there for a
while it was like it was probably gross
and then I think I put my put the own
the own app away you know got some
balance back in life yeah but uh I could
I could go for a new Addiction you know
I could go for some puzzle Rush this
year maybe I'll get back I don't know
why that came out of my mouth let's go
to the birds I view
um that's not a joke everyone should
take take their their their balance and
and H seriously you're right Chris
Krishna 21234 it's the Multiverse that's
at stake and we're going to go back to
the bird's eye view and see what else is
at stake we haven't checked in with
Christopher U the youngster from C let's
go go back back to C Cali and head and
head over to Christopher U when we get a
second big Chris there no one with a top
brush yet there's going to be updated
soon 27 minutes left stuff's getting it
it's round three there's five rounds of
this so two more rounds here so it is
getting you know it's getting sharp
you're gonna have to start bringing your
best in the last ones hopefully you're
ready we address this is on a computer
when when they started doing that Danny
yeah yeah for those who don't know Mr U
loves to solve themselves uh an iPad
he's an iPad solver um and uh preferred
the touch screen thinking you're going
crazy like but he's gone to the computer
so he's getting he's he's changing his
habits in his old age right we've seen
Christopher U on camera in this event
since he was sitting on phone books you
know what I mean he couldn't even get
his head over the chair for our webcam
like hey can someone get Chris a phone
book to sit on um we've uh by the way
you remember phone books remember
remember talking about industry I mean
is that a thing anymore I don't even
know know what I have to see if my
parents have an old one that'd be cool
to just like look through it like wow I
want me see if this number still worked
tell your kids about phone books anyway
uh yeah Chris has been here since he was
sitting on phone books solving puzzles
on an iPad he's on a computer but he is
a beast don't let that adorable face
fool you he's a monster um and uh one of
the best puzzle solvers around to be
honest yeah he was doing 55s on in I on
with the iPad you know crazy skill there
yeah crazy crazy skills we'll see if
he's one who can make it you know we've
talked about the fact that here in the
second round and every subsequent round
the bottom three will go home we haven't
maybe reminded the chat that the top
eight will move on to tomorrow so if
you're if you're new to the puzzles
World Championship we have this puzzle
Rush stage the uh the the players are
competing against each other without
having a direct pairing they can
actually see if you haven't used our
Puzzle Battle feature you should check
it out it's a blasty MC Blaster and The
Puzzle Battle tomorrow will'll see the
top eight players directly face off uh
which is even more nerve-wracking when
you can actually see how your opponent
is doing right in front of face yeah
that's nerve-wracking we play Puzzle
Battle every night too when you see even
I got I caught Ray one time in a Puzzle
Battle Pool and I was like why is there
not an abort option like can we do that
can we have can we put that in the
freaking don't nobody ever wants to get
paired with Ray in The Puzzle Battle
Pool and I just happenly got paired
somehow I'm like this is not even fair
you know so abort Miss abort
houon we have a
problem abort Mission Against r that is
that is pretty funny actually we don't
have an abort but that's that's a good
call out I mean obviously in the you
know in traditional chess we have an
abort button although if you become an
abort abuser we frown upon those people
here in the chess Community where where
so I mean you know we don't really want
you to do that Cy you can't just abort
because you're not happy with your
pairing you know I like y yeah I guess I
can't do we call those abort
abusers well especially when you get
paired with Ry there has to be like
maybe there's one for only when you play
Ray like well it's Ray you don't have to
play Ray you know that right like okay
thank you you know I'll take the option
yeah absolutely I I agree with that no
judgment on that
one all right well Christopher U has a
52 hey that rhymed it's currently got
him in third place you see Hans on
Twitch at number one Hans nean showing
up in his uh his first puzzle World
Championship in a minute but for those
who remember in 2020 I believe maybe it
was 2021 Hans deman was one of the top
puzzle solvers we'll see if he uh if he
continues on that path today gets
himself in the top eight at this point
he's he's performing in a way that we'd
be pretty surprised if he didn't make
the top eight at this point by the way
that's the that's the Lesser known
bortnik there in the top left sorry go
ahead KY that is no you're right in fact
I was saying 55 he's doing well but no
uh mention what you said yeah that's the
Lesser known bortnik there just as
strong just doesn't have it on paper yet
very strong and I think yeah he actually
you know his brother did make it through
which is the one we all we know more
which is Oland bornick and uh we weren't
able to see bordnick wasn't able the
other one wasn't able to make it through
unfor I think and for those who don't
know why maybe we know B the O exander
bortnik better obviously he has a much
more active streaming Channel but
bortnik really made a name for himself
in the bullet Chess Championship back in
2020 and ever since then we called it
Borton
when when you're putting up putting up
bullet performances like he has but yeah
the Lesser known bortnik I feel bad
saying that because it sounds bad but
we'll we'll tune in real quick to the
Lesser known bortnik right now if things
were to end I think he would be cut so
let's see if he can get a better than a
46 come on mola we're rooting for you
come on mola we rooting for you big dog
I watch sometimes I lurk in the Stream
and just watch them play and uh you know
it's it's always a pleasure watching
these players play so but this this is a
little bit different we got the puzzles
here's trying to figure it out moving
fast finding everything he made it this
far too as well very impressive someone
just made the Casey Affleck of the
bortnik brothers lesser known lesser
known Affleck brother ale yeah speaking
of Ben Affleck Ben Affleck is into chess
I don't want to really I don't want to
out Ben Affleck but he may or may not be
active on chess.com and um and maybe I
won't see it anymore but Ben Affleck is
is a chess guy so shout out to Mr Ben
Affleck I'm not sure where I rank him in
terms of Batman's if anyone sends him
this clip I don't really know that I
want that getting around he's not in my
top three I will say that but Ben
Affleck is into chess and we are into
that yeah that's fire that's great guys
you know the celebrities and the the uh
the the uh ball players now are into
chess chess is cool guys chess is cool
and you guys in chat are cool look at
that everybody just like cool around
here I knew I I chose the right
profession
you did you did look at that he just
went full Searching for Bobby fiser
there right not quite but he's got the
uh got the king and pawn end game Who
Queens
first what is okay look at that mola
bortnik he's still perfect I don't know
that the speed is enough but there he
goes he got a couple of easy ones yeah
he's not doing too bad here 35 with a
minute 30 yeah he needs like he's like
five off oh he has minute 40 okay I see
it now he's not too bad yeah
Bishop takes 95 96 there it is beautiful
queen there are very few things more
thrilling than smothered trapping a
queen and I'm I'm talking in life I'm
talking in life very few things feel
better I'm not that good in life nothing
like some people are mates you know with
the King but I'm in the smother traing
the queen there that is that is a tactic
with 96 come on CH intimidate
oh wow what is I don't know I don't know
the answer oh he oh Bishop E3 oh my
goodness this is ridiculous this is
Queen the queen slides over to a oh no
you just take it that point because the
knight's pinned yeah yeah the Knight was
pinned at the end on F3 that was
wicked whoa uh Rook AG six no that's not
enough oh no no no no no now he's there
you go he recovered not enough you
called it pawn three Pawn shorty oh oh
it was G5
it was G5 F7 it was King E7 yeah that's
a hard one oh man it's like Wicked dock
down there Bob it's wicked doc like what
oh shoot he said Wicked wow yeah check
check check mate okay there you go okay
now okay there you go wait no we're back
to zero I didn't realize he stopped I
was like yeah yeah he stopped I was like
what's going on here how was he doing
these in the 40s like yeah he re
restarted restarted the process
[Music]
it's wicked dark down there let's over
to the wicked view of the bird's eye
Mark wber called he's got a transformer
in the front yard really my brother told
me my brother told me I I'm telling you
right now all right ever since maah died
Tommy's been out of control all right
what do we got here um we have 43 51 50
5 who was that 56 oh Liam we haven't
seen the kid actually so you like yeah
the other kid that is Liam the other kid
the other one yeah they these guys are
going to be Rivals for a long time Andy
they actually played in the last us
Masters I was at which the game was a
draw Andy played a c and um Liam
responded correctly became a three
versus three on the same side Rick and
Bishop in game but became a draw so man
man that knowledge is just pouring out
of you pouring out of you hey man you
know as a young Jedi would because a
Jedi could is what I like to say young
Jedi would Jedi how much wood could a
young Jedi could if a young Jedi
could
uh would would would I don't know what
what a would what a young Jedi would or
could do um
exactly we've got we've got some fun
here if you're if you're H wondering
again who we're looking at in the lower
right you got Jims that's demitrus lulos
a name that the puzzle fans out there
the puzzle community has gotten
pretty pretty used to seeing I don't
know I think Jen is just not in shape
this year I don't know what happened
maybe he just not that or the
competition is stiffer yeah let's go to
Liam that's true I think I think the the
the competition's just stiffer bro I
mean this is like Liam Putman the other
youngster put
putam Liam putam already put put on
notice right you know what makes you
feel old when someone puts 2008 in their
profile and that's the year they were
born yep I know right I'm like oh I will
tell you what I have just lost my mind
on that one Bob I I that is he is born
in 2008 yeah bro 2008 y 2008 crazy yeah
and
uh you know someone left the truck
lights on staring through the window of
the basement oh that's bro look at the
lighting it's like oh Dad
Dad turn off the truck yeah it's like
like the angels are coming to it Gabriel
is blessing this particular puzzle
Rush are you going Halo did you just go
Halo humming I did I did he caught that
wow I caught
it the Halo hum is recognizable that's a
57 you been 57 kid eight look at that
he's checking the scoreboard I'm getting
Blind by the Liam putam 2008 again yes
year he was born oh makes me feel old um
he's checking out the score knows that a
57 is a good one he's he's aware that
he's doing just fine
now you were huming Halo my my daughter
was whistling the Kill Bill soundtrack
the other day watch the movie I'm like
did you I'm like where did you see Bill
like that was not
okay she is 12 years old and that was
that was like and it was like she had
heard it somewhere else but she was
whistling it perfectly and I was like
wow I didn't watch this together like I
don't understand how you know this yeah
that's that's great all right Liam putam
a youngster along with Andy Woodward if
you're just tuning in the kids have come
to play today we are hanging out with
the cool kids when it comes to puzzles
that is correct and I see these kids do
this every day I highly recommend guys
really if you definitely want to up your
game it is important to do honestly this
almost every day in a way is uh the kids
are doing this sometimes even like young
T too as well who's not participating
this year would constantly spend hours
every day doing Puzzle Battle hours
right so good to grind this stuff you
know and it really it does benefit you
in the long run why why isn't Tony
playing this year I'm gonna I'm gonna
shoot the F text I think it's a l with
school yeah dude School you gota I mean
okay hey I dropped out of high school
look how I turned out all right Kidd
that is not an endorsement you will do
your homework kids do your homework
right now go to go to doing homework.com
and do your homework all right I am here
to to tell
you you better be doing your homework if
you go to justdoing homework.com right
now kids you will know that you are
doing your job so let it be on record
that Danny wrench endorse kids to do
their homework by going to justdoing
homework.com Forever More that is the
good the good role model I am all right
let's go to
jpam oh yes jpam let's go man let's
go very strong J
54 yeah 54 is the
high can we get can we get the standings
brought up here in this view in a second
I just want to see where we sit if 54 is
on the cut Mark no he's in as this time
who is oh we saw that 57 oh there it is
okay that is Rono
sadani big fell also Liam as well yeah
Rono just he up out of nowhere yeah yeah
wasn't really talking about him too much
but he's at up at the top with Liam who
has 57 as well yeah we haven't updated
that yet but Liam putam we saw the 57
with our own eyes so he's tight at the
top we'll see if others continue to
shake out but yeah Jos
buum as I called out earlier for those
who don't know jbam is one of those
online freaks who kind of who kind of
just qu makes you question a lot of
things when it it comes to data and
stats but he has played more than a
100,000 chess games on chess.com and
that is not a typo there's no extra zero
there that is that is insan I have like
30k and I'm like 70,000 more games you I
feel like that's that's like a year hold
on Buddy we talking about years here now
maybe he doesn't have a lot of other
Hobbies that's what that is okay it
doesn't do anything else guys okay it
doesn't do anything else he ever he is I
wonder could someone could someone do
the math on how much of his life he has
spent on chess.com if Jos that's great
has
uh has has played a 100,000 games that
doesn't include puzzles doesn't include
anything else that's a 100,000 chess
games what what an animal that's all you
can say by the way speaking of animals
Hikaru just got to 56 that's better than
what he did in the earlier round the
heat is picking up remember the bottom
three scores will go home we are
eliminating people three by3 with each
round until we get to eight people who
will be those moving on to tomorrow's
puzzles World Championship final day wow
that's going to be amazing it's going to
be top level scorers uh through here
which is up I mean because the scores AR
very high just to stay in here you have
to be you know breaking 50s every round
and 52s to say the least now I mean look
at mlay strongest he is at the bottom 52
or maybe not at the bottom 45 there it's
the bottom Jims is not not doing well
bro 47 from Jus is it's just it's not
it's not notot and by the way we we I
mean we've been we've been focused on
the drama of who gets sent home cany we
forgot to highlight the other really
important stat in the format if you look
at that top line or the second line in
front of you right now the top two
finishers of each round get directly
seated so we're competing for two things
here with each half an hour boys and
girls that is don't get eliminated don't
be in the bottom three but those who
punch their ticket with the the top
score get an automatic seat into the top
eight and so that's why you don't see
Andy Woodward or Ray Shay Robson right
now battling because they took the top
two spots in round two oh they
definitely did that's very nice they
took those boy those spots there now
only a few spots left as they're trying
to get the best scores 10 minutes left
oh look at the oh the emotion ah let's
go ah
MOS
56 that's gonna that's gonna make him
safe
that's gonna make him safe oh man he is
he's still going let's go
bro you know like yeah let's go let's go
let's go ah you see all the players
they're checking in with the real-time
scoreboard that we give them you see the
bottom three are red that you know what
that means
right red is like Zed and if you are
under the age of 17 you should not have
seen Pulp Fiction one of the best movies
of all time but red is like Zed okay if
you know the reference that that's what
it means and
uh and yeah but 56 isn't enough to punch
your ticket to the automatic spot so you
gotta keep going josam you want to get
that automatic seat baby get that seat
baby look at him high he like yeah you
know this what we do he talking to CH
that's what we do it's nothing it's a
flex like easy work you know we got this
it's nothing to a boss big deal you can
see him flexing let them Flex let them
breathe let them do his thing that's
right that's right all right well let's
head back to the birds ey View when we
can because 56 is likely enough
currently Liam putam would be moving on
with that
57 we've uh we're gonna have a lot of
young kids tomorrow trying someone's got
a rise from the bottom to the top and
take down Ray Robson at some point here
but where we want to go next probably to
Jims I mean that's a guy who deserves
some time from us because that's a guy
whose
reputation precedes him his historically
arguably maybe the second best puzzle
solver in the world behind Ray Robson
but right now that is not the case so
let's go check out Jims when we can here
we need to change something first off is
it's impressive how small this board is
now to us it's this small but also I
know it's that small for him but like
okay I think he's on a laptop I think he
said what he used last year but this is
insane like you can't see I don't know
what piece is he moving right now no one
knows but he needs to definitely step it
up here as uh this is just not the gym
we're used to seeing that is able to
take on you know every
year if round three ended now Liam putam
and RX adwani will have punched their
tickets into the top eight remember
that's the puzzle battle World
Championship final day Manana with the
top eight battling it out with our
Puzzle Battle feature but Jim with the
small board man okay I was telling this
story early everyone remembers Larry C
The Legend Larry Christensen on IC the
internet chess club from back in the day
um I spent a lot of time with Larry C he
and I both taught at a chess camp for
many years he was a he was a coach of
mine um in a in a in for a hot
minute um but Larry Larry would do this
Larry was convinced that the smaller
board and the physical Mouse speed of
what it took to drag your mouse was
critical and uh yeah watching him play
on a massive monitor with the tiny
screen just always blew my mind yeah and
I actually started doing that now too
just cuz I know you can't I think that's
when I broke my high of like 49 on 3
minute was that was a smaller board but
small enough for everyone to see it and
also me as well because that drag time
like imagine dragging a rookie E8 to E1
is like going to be you know uh a lot of
dragging just that short little span a
half a second
counts y crazy well let's appreciate the
drama here everyone 47 would not be
enough to get it done right now for Jims
Demetrius lulos he I I if we were to
talk about storylines we talk about the
young kids coming up Andy Woodward Liam
putam if you're wondering Ray Shay
Robson and and Andy Woodward have
already directly qualified I see people
asking where's Ray he's already punched
his ticket but if there's other
storylines it would be it would be Jims
98 not making the top eight Cy that'd be
shocking but there we go we've got an
update so his best is actually 52 that's
good to know okay good 52 but I think
that's still okay yeah can we get the
standings here what is where does that
put him put him at the 10 I think around
tenis yeah I'm pulling
13 by tiebreak or something maybe
but yeah so he's right on the cut right
now right Dr down
52 okay this is a big round this is this
is his round he's perfect at 51 this is
this is huge oh he's perfect how much
time he got that's 20 seconds oh yeah he
could do it he could do it you got to
get a 53 though 52 is not cutting it
wish we could follow what he doing we
like come on buddy yeah you got it
what's the puzzle I don't know like you
got it 54 54 let's go4
come on
man 54 Jim he did it it is4
swinging 54 jumps him up to tide with
the top 10 he he's got
55 that's it 55 that's a one that makes
him feel good that's a big round look at
him tabing tabing the scoreboard tabing
the time remaining 55 makes him tied
with Christopher U Hans on Twitch so
he's currently tied for roughly six
through eth here in the third round and
that is a screen mirroring view of
OBS good job there you go good job I
love how you give me give me encourage
good job Dan to point that out obv good
job go back to your email big guy leave
the commentary to the
pros that's funny that's funny he's uh
he's up though he's up Mig a bortnik 53
okay how we looking 53 is all around
look at this one besides Jims he's right
there he just hit 55 yeah so very nice
well we got five minutes and I'd like to
head over to those on the cut and one of
the biggest names on the cut if the
scoreboard is accurate I know it needs
an update at least from what I can see
but what where is penguin gm1 that is
Andrew Tang Andrew T for those who don't
speak chess.com username and streamer
gang let's go check out Andrew Tang
who's currently on the cut I know he's
not in our Bird's eyee View
you okay let's go to let's go to mrava
for now but we'll we'll try to get Tang
up because he's the biggest name who
might be going home here so let's go to
mraa and we'll we'll get in touch with
with Andrew tangs here stream here in
just a minute but all right for those
wondering you got to get to 54 right now
53 still has him going home he's on the
cut I like his Pace this is how I
usually Pace as well just like half a
second um he had to take and play a four
he restarts that's a good good smart
strategy there with four minutes left
start agreed Town population US yeah he
gets this rush like gets this Rush clean
then he then he still has time to start
another one because I think he's very
aware of time remaining in the
scoreboard right now he just needs to
focus and get the job
done got it boom
boom all right tra's on the
cut Andrew Tang is on the cut your
choice Cy we stick mraa or we go to Tang
all right we're going to Tang we're T
tang with a bang bir I
view one of the fastest mouses in the
world in the
land what are the fastest mouses in the
land one man one
desire right and you know what's funny
like mouses and the mice thing like
mouses but mes
M no but it's funny when you're talking
about a mouse like a computer mouse you
like mouses I done that
but I'm like oh yeah I don't even know I
don't even know oh it was Bishop oh it
was Bishop E4 because you had to cut off
The Rook The Rook was coming back to E3
so it was Bishop E4 not Bishop A6 um
anyway yeah I'm not good at mouses or
mices I don't even know which grammar is
correct I went to the I went to the
school for kids who don't read good you
know and if you've seen Zoolander you
know that that school is a small
school it is a I'm with you wow it's
Moose's right mises m
m me's
Heist this is his his chance though oh
no okay you got to start again Tang
let's go let's go he got time two
minutes go go go all right we got two
minutes on the clock The Benchmark is 54
everybody you got to get to 54 to be
safe there are there are two players
with 53 right on the cut but I don't
know what the tiebreaker would be for
Tang so to be safe we're rooting for
54 oh come on he can do it it is very
very possible two
minutes hold the phone standings update
okay standings update he does have 54 it
was a rush we missed before we came over
so he's not on the
cut okay okay so who's on the cut who do
we have on we gotta back up we gotta go
to Jeffrey Jong he's in the bird's eyee
view Jeffrey Jeong is on the cut oh Jeff
Jeff Jeff cook up
Jeff okay this is epic Jeffrey Jong has
made the
semifinals multiple years in a row
Jeffrey Jong is a monster at puzzle
solving and if he doesn't make it even
to the top 10 I'm gonna be shocked so
this is this is it this is epic chef
chef going to cook up something special
and spicy here let's see if he can get
it
done okay he's perfect with 48 only only
50 seconds remaining
though can you spell drama push oh oh
you can see the agony the per especially
with 49 he like all right cool you got
to check the clock he has time if he
gets one come on bro it's got to be
Queen D5 just do it do it do it do it
there you go do it and then take the
rook and take you're good now you need
three more let's go you need three more
three more actually you gotta get to 54
he's got to get to 54 stupid puzzle yeah
oh my
God can get four so dud he's only got 15
seconds left you got it you got it
cannot miss this is if he misses he's
out it's Bishop B7 no it's Queen D5 okay
ah one Rook one the quiet he's got two
seconds no that's Jeff Jeff you got to
do another one come on Jeff come on wait
he got another one in he got another one
in he has time okay I thought that was
it I thought he was going home
that this is the run all right everybody
puzzle Rush rules in the puzzles World
Championship if the rush starts before
zero it counts we play overtime rules
here so this is it it is official he
either gets 54 on this rush or he goes
home
wow that's it Jeff come on you got to
give us his best dish right here Chef
Jeff come on chat can we get some energy
for Chef Jeff is he gonna make it or not
what do you think chck oh I am so
nervous we got three people on the cut
shout out to production bringing up all
three you're looking at them boys and
girls Maka bortnik Jeffrey Jong and
Grandmaster mraa are all fighting for
their lives this oh mraa has just been
eliminated it's official so he's out
over he's out he is out of there so we
have two we have Jeffrey Jong and zerber
right there but zerber according to the
standings I see here is safe Jeffrey
Jong is the one who we know for sure so
I say we Zoom back into Jeffrey Jong
when we can that's the uh that's the
name people are are just freaking out
about will Jeffrey not even make the top
eight day two of the puzzles World
Championship what a shocker that would
be that would be a shock as we've seen
it many times uh along the greats and
the finals there as it's going to be
difficult without Chef Jeff there no but
it just tells you how strong the field
is as you mentioned before um it's just
not a cakewalk here it is definitely a
different year 2024 and uh we have some
new participants and some younger
generation in here that is eaten up the
top the competition especially at thep
with Liam and you got your boy uh Andy
Woodward as well very strong showing
from those
kids Crazy by the way yeah we should
shout out Liam putam and Rano sadani
have officially punched their ticket so
we have four people four people
officially in the top eight they are
Raye Robson Andy Woodward Liam putam and
ronox sadw you saw hikaro Nakamura and
Hans Neeman both just missed direct
qualification at 56 despite hikaro
streaming his f favorite Bollywood song
the one he streamed during the bullet
Chess Championship that's just that's
just weird it's just weird played it he
just barely missed it but he did score
56 something about that song what is he
just getting his own levels up with that
song on dude speaking of being in the
zone he's got 30 seconds and he's at 50
Jeffrey Jong has not missed yet I
knocked down wood before he missed so no
commentators curse I did it I didn't
curse him let's go Denny let's go ah I
knocked on wood I knocked on wood there
was no jinxing there no Jinx yeah you
gotta let's go Jeff 54 don't jinx him
knock yes jeffes
his
Jeffrey he is not
eliminated like elimin 56 D dude he ends
up getting himself tied for third in the
end talk about clutch Jeffrey Jong
fighting for his puzzle World
Championship life gets the job done he
always does it that's why we call him
Chef Jeff because he understands when I
need to cook it gets cooked and he did
it 56 the man is in there very clutch as
chat says from
Jeffrey wow that was okay we just saw
drama there he started a rush with only
seconds remaining but overtime rules are
in play here so he has qualified we saw
two more people punch their direct
ticket that's RX sadani and Liam putam
hey Caro's listening to CH Chia what is
going on here candy take it away in fact
somebody just say car got 57 on the cha
CH song so first off I'm getting cha CH
on the playlist I'm just going to put in
there I'm G be at the gym they like he
just lifted everything I'm like I know
it's ch ch but at the same time you know
it's we're seeing a lot of things happen
here now a big shift in this year's
puzzle World Championship pretty nice it
is it is nice we're seeing the
youngsters come to play again Liam putam
born in 2008 he is a young human being
Andy Woodward at 14 years old uh putting
Ray on notice he was the highest second
score overall Ray put up a 60 today uh
Andy Woodward put up a
59 wowzers wowzers I don't know that
hikaru's tie breaks were good enough to
directly punch his ticket 57 means he
tied Liam putam and Rano sadw we're
getting the final standings up right now
so we can show you show you what that
looks like let's go ahead and do it
we're going to show you round three's
recap any Hooters boys and girls Liam
put and ROK were the ones who punched
their ticket and those that means ROK
did have better tie breaks than Hikaru
uh tie Breakers are are are several
we'll list them later hny but three more
players go home dude 53 not good enough
KY yeah 53 not good enough I mean you
know that makes that at home chat if he
feel some kind of way that's okay we all
do right now we just got to keep working
right and watch these guys do their
thing here as this is amazing 53 wow
didn't make it through the players
eliminated still got a lot left though
Liam doing a great job it's very very I
seen that coming though he plays da a
lot s to Da in chat too as well we saw
da here he say he's traveling couldn't
make it but definitely shout out to uh
Liam as he's uh definitely put on a good
showing Andy doing the same and a lot of
puzzles left a lot of matches shout out
to Liam shout out to Michaela bortnik
mola bortnik he's the Casey Affleck of
the bortnik brothers as someone in chat
said I didn't say it they said it the
Lesser known the Lesser known Affleck
brother goes home um but we're going to
take a quick break everyone else at home
this is your chance to get a snack get
ready because we're getting down to it
some of the biggest names in the game
will go home cuz they're not safe yet
you've got hiar Nakamura you've got
Jeffrey Jong you've got many others
fighting for their puzzled World
Championship life don't go anywhere
after this one we will be right
[Music]
back excellent this right here is how I
use chessable and why I've been using it
for a long time I mean if you look up
here here I actually have my streak it
says
1,231 days right you're going to forget
a lot of the things that are in the book
chessable came around when I got on
chessable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here there's going to be folders now so
I can categorize by white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is why I like so
they like how many chessable books you
got I'm like all of them how I use
chessable is actually I do a lot for the
opening training I do tactics on here I
do calculation I do ingame I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time chessable
is the wave this is why I like to use
chest was actually helped me I remember
even online I was only like capping out
at 2350 almost 2400 and and Blitz and
bullet my chess comom is 26 with a high
of 2774 and bullet and I blame all of
this like success really is just working
on chessable just being honest with
[Music]
you what's the best way to follow any
chess event from the World Chess
Championship to the candidates the speed
chess championship title Tuesday and so
much more chess.com events has all of
the top chess tournaments played both
over the board and online analyze and
review games from the world's greatest
players with live commentary cloud
analysis opening Explorer and table
bases find all the key event information
including schedules prizes results news
reports player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results explore chess.com
events today on web or with our IOS and
Android apps and experience chess like
never
[Music]
before
you
[Music]
e
he
[Music]
oh
I like your
[Music]
birds
h
it's puzzle time we live with GM KY
that's the man fed Master James candy
alongside me it's the 2024 puzzles world
championship this is one of my favorite
events this has been epic already we see
the kids coming out qualifying their way
Ray Shay Robson getting it done big
names being eliminated and sent home but
there's probably no name bigger KY than
the man hikaro Nakamura he wins chess
events for breakfast
uh you know sec's title Tuesdays what
want to call it but he's also a pretty
damn good puzzle solver and he looks
good in a blue suit yeah the man just
looking happy right he's like you know
I'm a streamer first guys I'm a streamer
first I don't do anything else like my
first job is being a streamer and then I
just happen to play chess very good so
of course as we see you know it just
helped him become very more calm and win
more events here as we see that puzzle
Rush score is 59 that is very beefy I
mean Ray being what is it was it 60 dang
that's 6 more than Ray I mean Ray had 10
more that's just Wicked okay that's just
insane bro wow but hearo being 59 is
very nice to when it comes to puzzles
all roads lead back to complimenting Ray
Robson you know it's just how it is but
yeah 59 is an epic all-time three minute
puzzle Rush score he's never broken that
six Mark will Hikaru do it today the
drama is on the line he'd love to
directly qualify for the top eight uh
but yeah it is crazy that Ray's best
three men of rushia 69 I don't know what
to say about that but here goes hiar
he's got the scoreboard
up yeah it's 10 I mean we're going to
listen into aaru uh summon this round
he's one of the biggest names still
fighting for his life trying to get into
day two of the puzzles World
Championship that will be eight players
competing in the puzzle battle final
final leg the grand finale for those who
didn't know what they were doing on
their Friday now you know um I can't
tell I want to give a shout out to
hikaro real quick no right oh you are
qualified no you're not qualified I
think I am no you're assumption don't
listen to we'll
see no but I'm playing my
I'm let's go let's go they just started
okay let's go they just started wait
let's
go thanks she just she's just answering
your questions and everything like just
man he's jumping in but all right now
that he's going to be focused not
talking quite as much I can give the
compliment to Hikaru that uh that y'all
didn't see coming I've been given
permission to out this because it is now
apparently public but hikaro is
personally sponsoring Andy Woodward I
don't know if you know that he's
sponsoring his travel and his coaching
hikaro is giving back to the Young
Americans and their future and Hikaru I
won't go into the details of that those
will remain confidential but Hikaru is
personally providing chess philanthropy
for Andy Woodward who look it's hard to
put this kind of pressure on kids
shoulders but if you don't know who Andy
Woodward is he already qualified
directly he's put up the second best
puzzle rush today behind Ray Shay Robson
which was 50
he's 14 years old and is one of the most
talented American players we've had in a
very long time so Andy Woodward is
personally sponsored by Hikaru Nakamura
and that's pretty cool for hikaro to be
doing that man that's fire bro giving
back to the community as much as you can
especially for the kids to it keeps you
sharp hanging out with them um training
with them giving them material a lot of
times can keep you staying sharp as you
age so it's very nice to see from you
Carl yeah it it is it's awesome and um
kind of kind of of uh kind of cool to
see OG Legend American players five-time
US Champions trying to give back to the
potential future there of top players
from their from their country right
there right now he needs to take a page
out of the book of Andy Woodward and get
get because right right now Andy
Woodward is is a better puzzle solver
than hiar Nakamura which is crazy yeah
right it's like hey man you know can you
Sponsor Me Andy in these puzzles My Guy
what's work hey Andy could you give me
some give me some puzzle advice give me
a tip S I need 59 buddy that's true
that's true but shout out to everybody
who's with us we had 7,000 of you
peeking on Twitch a minute ago over 4200
on YouTube and wherever else you're
watching thanks for being with us we're
having a bunch of fun today if You'
missed it we've rocked right up to that
line of decency that Danny has where he
crosses it so he knows what it is and
then doesn't go up to it again you know
we've made some awkward jokes that have
certain people spinning their heads you
know C's been flexing candy show them
what you got give me give easy this is I
mean come on this another day office
baby that's that's the bicep yeah we
curling 505s over here what y' curling
no no big deal no big deal anyway thanks
for being with
us oh this is such a fun event honestly
and it does make me want to solve more
puzzles yeah exactly tonight we're going
to do a lot of puzzle solving chat you
already know that so we're going to
solve a lot of puzz I'm just gonna try
to break like the high man you just want
to see these guys do it I hit 51
yesterday in five minute but that's like
you know I had two extra minutes like
what am I doing it's harder to it's
harder than you think so you know it's
leten important let's see it let's let's
listen in
toaru what you got Mike him up Mike him
up we got the music hey I'm going to do
the hikaro head Bob number
17 oh that's 17 that is that's good
that's a good one like that's him it's
like a not all the way Bop it's more
back than forward like yeah that's it
car headbob with the duck
lips y wow that's good you've been
watching hey how many people have
watched AAR Nakamura more than
me okay that's pretty good he's got a 53
spot here um let's let's hope for more
let's go Hikaru come on bro no no that's
number two ah sh Bo it stupid
that was a good that was a good puzzle
[Music]
going doc education says there's no way
I've watched AAR more than that's
probably true I won't I won't claim to
be the number but there you go KY give
it to
me come on y'all
hey
come on chat come on CH everybody
V everybody
V shout out to the to the those watching
on Kick they're giving a shout out to
the to the chess.com stream watching
them shout out to them watching us snap
shout out to them watching us watching
them FM Noah amazing chess 404 over
there on Kick giving a shout out okay
all right so real quick reminder for
everybody top eight are still dancing
tomorrow every round you advance in this
in this whatever we're calling the day
one the playin stage to the grand finale
tomorrow you get 200 bucks cash for
every round you survive which means that
all eight players who are dancing
tomorrow will already have secured a
cool Grand and then they're competing
for the better part of the $25,000 prize
fund so there's a lot of money on the
line tomorrow for puzzles and uh for
today it's h it's 200 bucks a round but
they don't care that much about that
they just they want to qualify the top
two players in this round four will
automatically take a spot to the top
eight and the bottom three will go home
that's how it
works yeah this is uh that bottom three
part is really tough because these guys
get very high scores that's the problem
like you're getting good scores but
you're going home like because you're
not hitting 55 plus every time which is
difficult it's shocking
right now where he at
47 I'm looking right now he but I'm
looking at the I'm looking at the
scoreboard over here too we've got pra
off at the top with 55 here in round
four Andrew Tang who was who was close
to the bottom in round three he's
already in the top two with 53 but we're
but we're young We're Young in this half
an hour segment of round four right
right and this uh who's at the bottom
okay 45s yeah 47 seven minutes in right
as you
said yeah we still got a lot of time
Jeffrey Jong with a 45 Hans on Twitch
has not put up a score yet he's
obviously been one of the top performers
here
today 50 55 from
Prav yeah Prav
55 I wonder if the scores will start
getting lower because everybody is like
getting a little tired a little energy
yeah like man hey bro when is this over
again yeah we got one more round
okay but yeah Jeffrey Jong was the stole
the show oh hikaro just put up a
57 hate
that he like yeah you know 57 we got it
done yeah we got it done I mean yeah
that was money let's go back to hikaro
if we can he's chatting away now we want
to hear what he's saying I don't know 57
I definitely feel good 57 guys come on
now that's a
three 60 to high from Ray on the first
round
yeah 57 is great though but we miss we
missed whatever he was saying but if I
was reading hikaru's facial expressions
and lips correctly I got him pulled up
over
here he said that was pretty good right
um and but he said will that be enough
that was his wonder is Will 57 be enough
to not only take one of the top two
spots but not get eliminated the the
stakes are getting higher right so we'll
see yeah check check let's see if he got
it let's see where he at what he 27
already okay we's see other boys looking
like 47
from that CR it for you that is
okay car on a roll here KN a good music
too yeah look at him got the head man
with the with the lips too like man
Danny was on point we are in this
together he's in a flow aaru is in a
flow
[Music]
oh I'm liking it oh it was Queen 3 and
night the other way getting too cocky
some getting way too cocky for no
reason no the reason there ising too
much time getting too cocky Vibe and two
puers at the same time bro and I know
this personally cuz we every night so
when I really want to get a certain type
of like good run I just do you can't B
you can't just can't yeah you have to be
100% a we're going to get his score
updated momentarily everybody but if
you're just tuning in his best Rush is
actually 57 currently not 53 but uh but
we'll we'll keep that updated for
everybody um but yeah I love that he
called himself out said he was getting
too cocky cuz he was happy he got a 57
so that was one of those where he was on
a roll but let it go so he speak Let It
Go Elsa let's head back to the bird's
eye
view okay I see it don't
uh you know don't lose your way Let It
Go in the snow Aden Manzel shout out to
rent greatest Broadway performances of
all time ad Manzel okay here we go
um we uh we've got four people
going I'm waiting to uh just see where
the drama's really at Jeffrey Jong stole
the show at the end of round three for
those of you who missed it he he was
eliminated at the zero clock if the zero
clock ended he was gone but he had
started a rush Before Time ran out and
in overtime put up his best puzzle Rush
of the day actually got a 56 right at
the end of the round three so let's go
to Jeffrey
Jong and let's go to Jeffrey Jong and
check him out
sh let's see what he doing okay 40 how
much time you got minute 30 okay all
right Jeff come on Chef Jeff there it is
looking
nice yeah okay takes King up got it oh
this is the classic yes he's on a
roll beautiful 45 with a minute to go
his best is 54 according to what we see
here che check Che he he's he's on a
roll Jeffrey doesn't want to be in the
bottom I mean you have to there we go
yeah wow
nice Queen D5 no Rook C8 okay F4 got it
again and out check
takes check check it's Bishop F5 Bishop
F5 oh
no I would have got that wrong I'm same
Bishop D1 was not where you're looking
that was oh that was nice and the bishop
had to go to D1 because you had to cover
the H5 Square so that was wild very nice
oh no two in a row that's a yikes he was
yeah yeah yeah it hurts he fell apart it
hurts and that might have been a
material that might have been a material
rush because will
54 be enough to punch the ticket see the
standings I gotta see where them boys at
see if the if the numbers going down wow
H's got pumped there he is pumped out of
his mind if you're watching his stream
there he's just absolutely
got super prompt I guess he just dropped
56 there it might be high for
him have to see who's left who's left
okay
well we're gonna check in right now the
top two let's go back to the bers eye
view the top two
people who would currently be moving on
are two of the biggest names left hikara
Nakamura and Hans Neeman Hans checks in
sees that he's number two there with a
56 again Hans is one of the better
puzzle solvers in the game the first
inaugural puzzled World Championship we
had back in the day again I'm getting so
old I guess this is year four so that
must have been
2020 yeah because uh yeah yeah I'm doing
my math
good uh so yeah we've got we've got
uh hikara with 57 and we've got Hans
nean with 56 those would be the top to
as you see it who's on the cut I'm
looking over Christopher U would be
going home right now Jus 98 is right
there on the cut and mlay mlay in the
upper right I say we go check out
wonderful time because he's on the
cut and
uh and that's that's big time mlay would
not be moving on if the clock hit zero
right now according to theore I can see
now Men actually when he's in the zone
he is twirling his hair I mean like him
and uh David pavian they it was they
look like twins it was like the H the
twirling Championship as they when they
were playing each other they and they
Twirl in the same spot as well it's like
a thinking thing that they do so men is
locked in but 49 30 seconds 4 and 30 and
he just missed that one that was not a
good this struggling here this one's
struggling oh this one I have no idea oh
my goodness rookie is a rookie okay Rook
H4 the A8 Rook is hanging that's the key
oh that's stupid Rook d59 I mean Rook
e495 come on
bro absolutely can he catch a break can
he get a break like man he he he needs a
break right now because right now he'd
be going home he's at he's at 50 that
score is accurate and so if we ended
he's out along with guess who Jim is 98
the legend Demitrius lulos would not
currently be moving on every year Jim
has made it and this is this could be
the first time here but we noticed that
too he just wasn't hitting the numbers
we wasn't mention his name as usual and
it's like what is going on well first
off we do have Andy and we have you know
um um Hans we have Prav right we got
these new players Liam going crazy right
like this is new this is a new thing new
competition here yeah it's crazy it's
crazy new world it is a puzzle s world
and I am a puzzle solving girl or boy
whatever you know whatever guys it is it
is wild what's going on these days with
puzzles because the scores are getting
better again if if you missed it earlier
55 oh no it was 54 54 was the required
score to get in to the top 20 we had 99
streamers show up for this record
turnout and year before it was 49 so the
community has gotten that much better
the competition is absolutely insane
when it comes to puzzles wonderful time
got to pick it up here yeah he's got to
pick it up bro he has to but he has time
the good thing is I have time 14 minutes
so I just breathe through it I got to
work take my time I can do it I can
definitely do
it definitely do it he can't get it I
believe in in what's it I don't remember
his high overall
today yeah he he had a 54 for I me okay
for sure cuz 54 was was required to was
required yeah yeah I think I think he
had a 56 actually if I remember in the
first in the first round um I could
obviously be misspeaking um but uh
someone in chat spreading spreading
false rumors says that you still get
paid if you don't laugh at my jokes I
said that's not true he actually doesn't
get paid if he doesn't laugh at my jokes
that's exactly right I mean come on guys
doesn't matter even if he's like you
know breathing I laugh that was funny
Danny oh my goodness did you see our
light our lie detector video where like
Le couldn't answer whether he thought I
was
funny yes guys go check the LI detective
video right now if you haven't on
YouTube that was pretty funny that's
hilarious just. I think of all the
questions that were hard to answer and
we had we had some good honest honest
moments with each other we were
vulnerable with each other but I think
him not being sure if he thought I was
funny might have been the most
heartbreaking moment of my life like
that was that was top 10 top 10 dog yeah
take good exactly right light detector
wasn't working on that one I'll tell you
that right right that's
good all right well we've got our Bird's
ey
view we've got jimas I think we should
go to Jims I mean he's earned it right I
know he's not a top grandm top title
player in the game but this guy has
dominated the field for years and he's
currently on a good rush let's knock on
wood and go to Jims and see if we don't
jinx him but he would not be moving on
53 is not good enough at this stage can
he do better right now
KY 53 is possible but he has not been
you know he hasn't been performing today
not to say that he can't do it but this
is now the time if you don't do it now
you may not have another shot you might
just be eliminated here so it has to be
now whatever it worked in the previous
years I mean maybe he has to bring it
out now or just get out of his own head
whatever's going on it's not the gym
we're used to seeing that keeps up with
Ray in these type of
formats yeah but again I mean the uh I
think Ry did Ray things to qualify for
those tuning in Ray didn't not show up
he's already qualified so he's not still
competing at this point but but I just
think the community has closed the gap
on jamus a little bit to be honest I
mean KS showed up the the lung the lung
I combined Liam and young the lung Liam
putam Andy Woodward right now you've got
oh by the way I didn't see a scoreboard
change at the top Jeffrey Jong just put
up a 58 so right now Jong and Hikaru
would be moving on Chef Jeff my guy that
boy 58 he cooked up I'm telling you wow
when he cooked up you going to taste it
you going to know it's there Chef Jeff
with a 58 that's great by the way this
is this is a big round for Jims because
he's taking his time in perfect but he's
not solving fast enough and that's he's
already down to it when that clock goes
red you almost
dead uh
oh 52 come on bro how much time he okay
he has time but you know are we going to
keep saying this at minutes CF still
trying to break into it yeah it's just
not the same Jims I you know very
impressed by him still always but it is
just not the same jemus that I've seen
to face Ray every
year yeah he's uh he's on the edge and
he's checking the scoreboard almost in
disbelief that 53 has him in red but
that's where we at at this stage by the
way PR putting up a 57 as well that'll
get updated in a second so Jeffrey Jeong
hikaro and prono are the top three Hans
right behind them with 56 punching that
ticket the moment you get in the top
eight you safe and you want that because
this is going to come down to some real
drama shout out to chat talking about
the LI detector video I invited Anish to
do the lie detector video next for those
who suggested it Anish is too nervous
Anish is too nervous because he doesn't
know how honest he wants to be about his
life on social media and everything else
so go to go to anish's chat the next
time he's streaming and call him out I
even said I would fly there and do the
lie detector with Anish giri right
that's going to be epic
content let's get epic yeah put some
more comments in there in the YouTube
channel some more comments of people you
would like to see on a l detector video
CH maybe you'll see more that's right
raw content that's
right
um
okay nice what do we got here what do we
got I'm looking at the people on the
cusp there we haven't checked in the
shock spiler don't know who shock
Spiller is someone says that's the
international Master Christopher Noah in
the chat that's from IBS G thanks for I
I say we go there let's go to
International Master Christopher noi
Noah definitely definitely I like giving
I like giving the love to the Lesser
known stars of our community and
Christopher Noah is is obviously one of
them not a household name necessarily
but clearly one of the best puzzle
solvers or he wouldn't still be dancing
at this stage that's it he's yeah
exactly he's here he may not be making
it out but you know if if you if you do
if you get eliminated it's still good
things to be happy about you know you
get you made some money today you also
are um you know you just say you can say
you compet it with the best of the best
here I made it this far I knocked out
but you know there's good things in the
future hopefully for me type thing so
always good spirits and he has time
eight and a half who knows what can
happen maybe he locks in and hits that
second or third gear that he needs to
hop into you got to do it the standings
as far as who would go home in the
bottom three still have them like we saw
him it would be Jims 98 Christopher Noah
right here and mlay wonderful time so if
we ended right now those three would not
would not still be standing their puzzle
World Championship campaign comes to an
end if they can't do better than a 53
got to be a 54 that's crazy yeah I would
have been knocked out I'm like 50 like
happy with a 50 51
happy I've never been so happy to even
think about the number 50 like I I
I can't even smell 50 I think I think
mine is I think my best is a 47 I
shouldn't I shouldn't say nice bro yeah
I have to check my profile I think it
might be higher go to my profile real
quick some heat let's go to my puzzles
what what is my best puzzle Rush of all
time my puzzle
bash oh no should no it's not that good
at all my my best puzzle Rush score for
3 minutes 36 I haven't solved in a while
that is not you haven't solved though
exactly you haven't Sol that seems like
a data error at chess.com can we get we
get a data check on
that I think my best puzzle Rush wasn't
recorded ex okay I
just that doesn't feel good to talk
about on okay I feel like Ron Burgundy I
just read what the teleprompter said and
I feel like I read something I wish I
could take back on camera but you can't
take it back it's already out there it's
already C shipped it's online going
online everyone's going to see it
they're going to know what I'm about
that's right do it right all right all
right okay Christopher Noah is on 40 and
perfect let's go come
on perfect everyone's best wasn't
recorded a server bug damn.com exactly
it wasn't recorded come on chess I know
why we play on this site it's crazy we
be on here every
day all right okay I've got my eye on
Hikaru over here too he's putting up A's
he's almost perfect in 40 as well so
we'll see if he can get even better than
his current
57 whoa this spicy takes I take the yeah
this is this is where it
matters right Christopher no we're gonna
stay here and if if it doesn't get
better for Jims that's where we're going
next because that's the guy the biggest
name in puzzle
solving history who would not be moving
on today to day two If he if he can't
turn it around so that
so maybe put some real fire under him
too as well lat in the future of like oh
no I made it this many years now I
didn't make it I wasn't even close in a
way you know that's like oh no what am I
doing wrong let's fix that especially in
the New Year still in the fresh first of
the new year there's lots of time to
make changes and also to be inspired
maybe try to you know make it next year
also for you guys watching too as well
maybe some of you may be able to compete
next year but it starts with working
like you see these guys doing that one
hurts but he got time he has time as
he's checking something he's got time
he's checking his scoreboard he's one of
those guys who's conscious of his stream
and didn't just tab to it he's like he
didn't want to ruin his stream everyone
else is just like I don't care what
people see they can see the scoreboard
I'm I'm I'm doing work but right he
probably was just turning over to his
scoreboard Monitor and went oh crap 52
is still
eliminated um but all right let let's
head back to the bird's eye KY because
the four you see are the bottom four as
they stand josam would be moving if the
clock hits zero right now the other
three are fighting for their lives Jus
is just quitting rushia if he misses one
early at this point he knows he's got to
put one of his best ones
together maybe yeah mlay up in the
corner on a decent run right now so I
don't know where we want to go we could
go to mlay we could go to Jus I kind of
want to go to mlay cuz he's on a roll
this has potential yeah let's let's go
to min Che out man this could be his
moment we'll see if he owns it thank you
Eminem mom spaghetti let's do
it big man for the win this is his
moment you better own it right so City
see if he gets it he F5 nice with H6
being the next come final come on man
this is real life this ain't no movie
it's no Makai
Fifer that one
hurts I mean that was a tough one though
oh this one was stupid yeah and it's
like yeah I've okay never mind it's not
that one it's a creation of one F5 takes
I I hate I hate those endgame puzzles
nothing makes me more angry at chess.com
and
myself defitely definitely oh 100% when
we get those and you know we do the
Clean 50 every day all greens and on 49
we get a deety that they didn't even
they put in the book and then we like oh
yeah we gonna put this it's Danny's
fault it is Bishop a 3 oh rest check I
think it I don't know and checking
rookie or something stupid no it was
Queen E1 Queen
E11 oh gross and then Queen B4 I closed
my eyes I looked up at the ceiling I
went full Hikaru and I knew it was Queen
E1 Queen E1 there it is Chad close your
eyes and
breathe Jer snaps by the way Hikaru is
also not out of the woods if you look at
the standings mlay as you can see is
fighting for his life but Hikaru has
still not punched his ticket to the
final day I think I speak for everyone
that we would want him in that puzzle
World Championship but uh the drama is
real Because unless he puts up a 508 he
has worse tie breaks than pron off as
you could see there hikaro would have to
play and go down to the final round
wow this is coming up guys two and a
half minutes
here oh man and a look I love mlay and
and we are having a wonderful time
watching him but but I think we I think
we got to go to Jims that's the guy who
deserves it right now because he's been
through hell and back with the puzzle
Community as far as as far as how
popular this event has become how much
people love puzzle Rush this guy made a
name for himself accused of cheating
showing the world that he's capable of
competing with the world's best Grand
Masters but this would be the first time
he doesn't make it to the second day of
the puzzle World Championship but will
he get 54 right now it's 54 or bust 54
or well here have one more he have one
more maybe he'll get one more but oh man
it's gonna be tough
right he got 54 now does he have better
tie breaks than josham we don't know yet
55 he like what you mean tie break what
what is that tie breaks what look at him
looking at the
scoreboard taking breath breath there
jimis 98 by the way he has not punched
his ticket to the second day but he's
still alive that's what he did he kept
his day going
he got the dub he got it done he got it
done Jus is still in it still in it
maybe shaky but it's still in it
sometimes it happens doesn't matter how
you get it it matters if you got it done
and you got it done absolutely wild
right
now mlay is still on the cusp now josam
is on the cusp actually oh my gosh that
was the that was the biggest change oh
yeah the gym is yeah and Jos from 54
yeah we got to go to josam now I think 3
1 two three fall off yeah josam falls
off J fall off 100,000 games played on
the server that sounds like the
beginning of like an Alexander Alexander
Hamilton like 100,000 games played
100,000 letters written I it was like me
I loved for him me I died for him and me
I'm the damn fool that shot
him wow there's a million games josam
hasn't played but he's played 100,000 of
them you know what you should get like a
jacket or something something specially
made for that we should you know you're
right something nice someone clip ship
it yeah someone clip that and ship that
to me I want to remember we're gonna
we're gonna give people some sort of
gift basket when they play 100,000 games
that is how many games I got I'm about
to check right now I'm about to go check
got a long way to go
bro you got a long way to go I got a
long way to go CH I'm about to check
right now hold on let me see
okay but if you're curious way to go
yeah we got a long way to go if you get
100,000 let's go back to the bird's eye
because as we can see it the bottom four
so so Jos bom is fighting for his life
he is going home if it ends right now
but he's tied with Andrew Tang Andrew
Tang has better tie breaks that's why
Andrew Tang would still be alive there
you see in the lower left the Peng
penguin
gang penguin gang V4 yeah where is he at
he's at seven o but then
they just changed it up a little bit
looks good oh I got 55,000 games okay
I'm still way way bro I got 55,000 55190
right now that's maybe next year we'll
see man I love it I'd offer you a
personal hug but I give you those
anyway oh man dang man we'll get some
kind of custom merch but all right all
right the two on the two on the right
are really up against it everybody 51
and 52 not going to do it you know what
they have to do you got to get to at
least 54 to be tied and hope you have
tie breaks but 55 is safe Jos buum is
going home if he can not do better than
his current 54 and if he were to do it
he would Leap Frog penguin and Andrew
Tang would be the one eliminated wow
this is uh your fate is in your own
hands kind of type thing definitely
drama here
yes yeah this is get back to back 56 is
oh that's some heat 56 back to back Joe
Biden there I have to
I gota get
51 man Joe Biden there in the chat he's
his name I know his name is I thought
you were making some sort of funny Joe
Biden comment like wait hold on that
went right over my head the point the
point sailed just over me but that was
hilarious I'm like we're talking
politics this is the wrong stream bro
it's the wrong
stream oh man this is crazy username
right it's official Christopher Noy is
on we love you way to go everyone go
give him a follow but he has been
eliminated we're watching in real time
right here can wonderful
time yeah big shout out to Christopher
can wonderful time do the impossible at
seems oh it's coming down to
it make sure you give all these
streamers a follow Oh josam Come
onone Oh he's out no it's over it's over
for josam no dang which means Andrew
Tang Andrew tang and there you go mlay
we saw it in reverse order one two
three Christopher Noe mlay and then Jose
Martinez also known as Jos they all go
home C they're out unbelievable to me
like I look up to those guys you know we
all do the jsums and the big men's for
the wins like it's he's out they're both
out there gone you know what I mean
that's crazy it's very
competitive Andrew Tang shows the the
mouse speed there but he came down to
the wire that's not how you want to
squeak by because he wasn't in control
of his own destiny there not putting up
a great Final Round And if josam had had
Lea frogged Andrew Tang would have been
sent home but uh we're getting the final
standing set but I believe we at least
know who punched their ticket and that
is Jeffrey Jong and PR off the Buddy of
the chess bra channel that means hikaro
Nakamura and Hans Neeman are still
fighting to get in two of the biggest
names left remember only eight players
are still dancing Manana we know six of
them candy I'm can you see my heart
first of all my heart exists For You
Second of all I love you I love you
secondly it's beating out of my
chest wow out of my chest right now or
maybe you just did chest day maybe it's
chest day chest day that wasn't chest
day today but there you go put those
things down we got kids
with you we got kids watching here oh
man this
is this is wild this is so much
fun this is fast it's
Furious it's dramatic let's go let's go
to our day four recap our round four
recap not day four round four recap here
who moved on as we said it was Jeffrey
Jeong and POF but the three eliminated
Jose Martinez Christopher Noe and minl
KY you're your thoughts again on that we
got one more round here and of course
people are trying to punish their ticket
here it definitely is me for the josin
fans you were thinking he was going to
win men fans like all the fans here even
bordnick fans going back even that far
too as well thought that they would make
it through they're just not making it so
you don't know what's going to happen
here so I'm excited to see who get those
last two
seats the action has been wild it has
been Fast and Furious shout out to
whatever the next Fast and Furious Vin
Diesel movies coming out I hope that
there are still people I'm not going to
talk about that but you know what's not
fast T Steel chess let's talk about that
because we're going to have coverage of
the classical the most classical of
classicist events in to of Steel and
guess who's back ding Lee Ren mofos the
world champion has showed up he is
competing in tata steel along with so
many others you see him right there
you've got xuanjun you've got prananda
you've got Anish giri it's going to be
epic I can't wait to see what happens
right there but yeah Tod steel that's
the chess tournament that everyone kicks
off their year with just after the
puzzle world championship and uh for a
change of pace you're going to want to
check that out all right we're going to
take a quick break when we come back it
is the final round of the first day only
two spots remain in the top eight for
the 2024 puzzles world championship and
Hikaru Nakamura is still fighting for
one of them don't go anywhere we'll be
right
back any good chess tactics book has one
pattern in it that feels like it is on a
completely different level than all of
the other tactical patterns bearing the
Vivid and accurate moniker the windmill
this pattern features an amazing
sequence of repeated discovered checks
that can be used to win a nearly
unlimited amount of material the most
famous windmill is definitely the one
played by Mexican Prodigy Carlos té
against former world champion Emanuel
Lasker but Bobby Fisher's game of the
century also features a windmill here's
another one that I really like white
starts with a rook sacrifice that leads
to a combination of Bishop and Rook
checks that simply consume Black's
forces the lefong is a dirty dirty trick
that will probably only work at bullet
but you have to pull it off at least
once in your life when you sense that
your opponent is pre-moving G6 and
Bishop G7 to start the game you can play
D4 and Bishop H6 to try to win the
bishop on G7 guys no one is watching
oh they all missed that I see the Tilt I
can feel the
tilt
it is a highrisk and high reward
strategy because you are hanging your
own Bishop if you don't catch them in a
pre-move but it is certainly hilarious
when you do pull it off like one of my
friends AOS he made a um bot the report
CH was ba partly based on hyper bullet
games so then you can see a lot of the
Leons and queen C2 takes H7 and so on
[Music]
so
chess kid is going live and in person at
the chess kid national
festival bring the whole family meet
your favorite Chess
Masters solve
puzzles play K8 tournaments compete for
the chess kid Festival championship
title and so much more this Festival is
surely won for the books from February
16th to the 19th 2024 in Charlotte North
Carolina book your seats now before
they're
[Music]
gone
you
[Music]
e
I like
birds
[Music]
the puzzle world champion ship final
moments of the first day only eight will
move on and dance tomorrow for the
better part of the $25,000 prize pull
and who knew that the Cinderella stories
would be hikaro Nakamura and Hans Neeman
on Twitch these two guys are two of many
that are still fighting for those final
two spots but uh it's going to be
dramatic KY for sure absolutely as you
see on the screen there I mean big dogs
do big things there but there only going
to be room for only two of them as I
think we have a what is it four or five
they need to qualify still but two are
trying to take this spot here hikaro is
he gonna make it is H gonna make who's
gonna make it I don't know in fact GNA
make there a lot of other a lot of other
players who want to who want to say
something about that if we pull up the
standings you also have Christopher Yu
uh by the way a guy named Demetrius
lulos Jims 98 who I would not be betting
against at this point and Andrew Tang
this is this is nerve-wracking no matter
what
either hikaro Nakamura is not in day two
or
jimas the arguably second best puzzle
solver we've had over the last several
years in the world will not be dancing
or you'll have other big names like Hans
nean Christopher Yu or Andrew tang go
home so this is huge I'm nervous I just
sat up a little bit on my chair which is
what I do when I'm a little nervous and
uh here we go hiar evil Ranger actually
in chat says toughest round of the day
that is the easiest way to sum it up for
anyone watching this is the toughest
round of the day 100% and it's not even
close because they're tired at this
point right I mean that's why that
golden ticket that golden ticket has
been so valuable but Hikaru Hans Andrew
Tang Jims Christopher none of them have
punched it yet and I think OB
objectively Hikaru has probably played
or I guess solved the best of the of the
last five remainings so far because he's
been tied for the score that punched the
ticket into the top eight twice now if
my math is correct he's been tied for
that score but he didn't have good
enough tie breaks so yeah anyway I don't
know if that means anything but hikaro
should be feeling some momentum going
his way look at that top Rush seven look
at that chat y'all can compete with hi
CaRu okay you know it's something to
make you feel good about yourself you
know what I mean if that's where you at
that's where you are you know you got to
be at terms and okay with yourself you
know what I mean so if that's where you
are that's where you are but you just
get
better
will you will you be my motivational
speaking coach will you you just
anytime words that are coming out of
your mouth you know right feel good
first of all seven is the most powerful
magical number and that is the
number
that's that is a it's a feel-good story
right there if you can get seven and be
in the puzzles World Championship but
Jokes Aside Hikaru currently has 38 uh
sometimes there are real feels good
stories sometimes we use the term
feelsgood story to say that something
was not so good but at least it feels
good that's kind of what we say what
it's about even giri himself of course
the legendary of the Legends giri says
that uh when you feel good you play good
but did he get one wrong there he did he
got one wrong and he and he he he sh he
he got to 40 and was still perfect with
a lot of time left but getting that one
wrong was was less than IDE as they say
look at that he just quit he just quit
after that all right another r that
makes sense another one let's go yeah
get it
done get it done oh oh no oh no oh no
okay he just he just purposely moved him
WR he's like all right it's gross right
now hold on bro not ideal not ideal
there hikaro needs to pull it together
let's listen into the
man maybe maybe if maybe if the music
gets
going he'll find his his Mojo
yeah sometimes you know music gets you
flowing but then when you start bopping
you like sometimes even moving while
you're moving you mess up the
mouse oh oh my oh my God what am I
doing and nobody does the same puzzles
no it's your own puzzle
[Music]
Rush yeah I mean it's possible for
people to be served the same puzzles
but it is your own puzzle rush and you
see he's he's still chatting he's still
engaging with chat but
uh come on for the content taru for the
content for the content you always do it
for the memes and the content as he says
for the
memes I'm suddenly not seeing the board
I'm like I'm missing everything I'm
missing where the pieces are okay well
you have to think about this to how many
has he done number one how many puzzles
has he done today think about that
number two and number three is I mean
this is like 30 minutes every single
time it's round
five
yeah no jokes aside this isn't going to
cut it hikaro knows it as he said and
you feel bad cuz he said he's not seing
the board well that's a sign of fatigue
that's a sign of being tired if you just
tuned in we've had a lot of fun today we
are many hours into this show right now
and uh and it's yeah it's coming down to
the wire these guys are all
tired yeah it happens it does for see
and this is why you know you can
actually apply this too I always tell
this to like students and people in chat
like you can apply this to actually to
your blitch highs to your new high
ratings wherever you get like you go
down yeah I went down up 100 points and
then you're down 200 like when you are
fatig it is good to just you know stop
in this case you can't stop but it is
good to just take some points and get
out of there
yep by the way we'll we'll we'll
obviously get into it it's it's uh it's
Young this last round five meaning we
still have a lot of time left but
currently Christopher U has a 54 and
Andrew King has a 53 they would be
moving on at this Benchmark although as
we said a lot of time
left lot of time when I get tired I eat
a cinnabun and get Renewed Energy nice
okay cin going out there don't take diet
or health advice from twitch chat do not
take that advice that's a pro tip huh
that is a
I get a cinnabun bro and a Diet Coke hey
bro you know what hey man buddy you can
have it again let's talk
nutrition takes takes very
nice I I am so irritated with YouTube
right now the inability for me to get
chat up higher instead of be fully
zoomed in on these stupid ads I'm sorry
I'm sorry venting on YouTube I was
trying to reject there was a great
comment a great comment from Dr delirium
who said you got to love hikaru's taste
in music I agree and then I was trying
to I was trying to connect with you
YouTube chat but YouTube chat interface
sucks I hope that they hear it like so
many things about the actual experience
there you
know okay we're back to H let's focus
Dan Focus hey Dan
Focus hey Dan hey
Dan okay here we go thanks
there it is there it
[Music]
is yeah he's just not having any still
the runs he want seem like a better
better rush at
least Bree through
it so where did that put him at
51 but by the way we talked about how d
ous it is to be Hikaru to be Hans nean
to be any of these guys going up against
really one man who somehow is still here
fighting for one of the top eight spots
and that is Jims 98
the the weakest chess player and I say
that with all compliments I mean it's
okay because he's going up against a
bunch of really strong players here but
Jim is 98 got a 54 uhoh but look it here
comes Christopher Yu he got a 55 just
like for you he heating up what it do
let's go let's
go heating up
he's heating up takes takes
takes I feel like I'm just getting too
tired
now I don't know there is fatig I mean
it's understandable bro he 30 I mean try
we always say like try it yourself you
know the for the people that are like oh
man you know you're getting old or it's
this and that excuses you just have to
understand it from their point of view
try 30 minutes five rounds of yeah this
is I I'm I'm exhausted for them at this
point and all I've been doing here is
making cringe jokes for the last 4 hours
you
know I do this every day of my life
every day your life I'm exhausted and I
haven't done anything that's crazy wow
oh man what exactly is it that you do
here Dan hey Dan what would you say it
is that you do at chess.com I mean I do
the bro what you know we got a laugh
what what is it that you do here Bob
um yeah let's freaking game what was
that this this is so
scary we're going to stay here car was
only miss one this is this is a big
chance for him come on we have to like
run like look at this nonsense this is
stupid this is this is
absolutely one out the bro come on Danny
that's your puzz
[Music]
you trade Queens to win Y what he saw it
y yep oh my God what a puzzle I know I
know's this I don't know on uh finds it
takes check King D2 perfect out of
there
unbelievable back to move what do you
even do work takes D4 ooh nasty oh wow e
wow F4 not the move r no it was I know
what it was oh it just Rook G2 but a
king H3 oh I guess you do hfg or
something why is it this just Bishop no
this is not good enough it's just not
good enough I need I need like
57 hopefully that'll spark me though cuz
that was a pretty good Rush
overall agreed to everyone else can hear
Hikaru too
right I I I'm getting confused whether
I'm listening to a or everyone is or
yeah that was a good Rush he had it I
don't know why it wasn't Bishop of3 I'm
sitting here I'm still just thinking
about that puzzle in my head I feel
that's that's wild but yeah hikaro said
it would have to be 57 currently it
would have to be 56 as you can see on
the score or okay it would have to be 56
or 55 cuz the top two move on if you're
just tuning in you see the format right
there below the scoreboard the bottom
bottom three are eliminated the top two
move on we've been doing it for several
hours it's been a blast honestly such a
fun event um but we have real drama here
at the end if aaru qualifies they'll say
it was for Content you know that he did
badly just so he could get the content
54 be good enough for anybody though I
think 57 is required I
thinkir I think he's I think he's
probably right someone's going to get on
a run here H it's 19 minutes
too yeah I think we got I think we got
enough time someone's going to get their
going to get their Rush on you know guys
r s either ways for Content exactly Hans
dropped to 54 okay okay what's up chat's
good who you think is going to make it
through Chad let's get some predictions
who do you think is going to make it
through last two spots who is going to
make it through we got some Heavy
Hitters here some favor that you would
like to see who is going to make it
through
T takes check push thanks chat I fixed
my YouTube chat so now I can chat with
YouTube as well I just said hi over nice
heyi hey
YouTube we got almost 5,000 of you on
YouTube 7500 on Twitch people love
puzzles people love puzzles don't you
love your puzzles chat I hope you doing
puzzles today or at least created to be
a habit for you at least you know 5 10
puzzles a day take 10
minutes hey I love it this public
service announcement is brought to you
by someone who does one thing over
everything and that is
calculation me calculation over
everything over
everything 100% get it done 100% let's
go 100% where we at 39 and how much time
is that a minute 30 can't really see his
time I think that is a minute
let's let's zoom out here and maybe stay
in the bird's eyee view I mean we can
stay here if we want cuz zaro's got a
rush going well we'll move we'll zoom
out but we'll take a look at where we
sit right now of the three you see only
Jims would be moving on Christopher Yu
is currently still number one with a 56
by the way the kid getting it done
getting heat some heat there yeah Hikari
was right I think 57 is the only safe
number because at this point 56 ties and
you know who knows what the best streak
is which is the first tiebreaker how
many you solved in a row for those who
who didn't read the puzzle world
championship format but yeah this
is this is exhausting for these players
they've been solving puzzles at a high
level for hours now players like Ray
Robson Jeffrey Jeong the kids Andy
Woodward and Liam putam have all already
qualified the players you see are
fighting for their puzzle World
Championship lives
and uh Jims I mean again if that guy is
as great as Hikaru is obviously you've
got Andrew tang and Hans Neeman big
names in the game but if Jim doesn't
make it to day two that will be the most
surprising thing for me KY yeah of
course it'll be the biggest up uh
basically in a way upset of uh since
we've seen puzzle ble World Championship
since the start of it because Jims was
here every year he was like the you know
the guy right behind Ray but now we
don't know who that is a fact I mean it
looks like Andy is the guy right behind
Ray right now and not Jim Jim not even
top three four you know if speaking of
behind Hans nean Hans Neeman just put
everyone else behind besides Christopher
youu with a 56 56 so Hans nean would
would right now be dancing in day two if
the clock expired hot he hot he hot he
got the hot hand let him Rook chat let
him Rook with 15 minutes left with 15
minutes on the
clock yeah uh I uh I I like I like the
the run the Tang is putting up down
there still
perfect still poking still perfect there
very nice trying to push himself into
that you got to get 56 at this point to
even be
tied that is ridiculous just to think
about like man is that's some heat those
puzzles are not easy anything not e at
all be serious and it's so hard because
you just got to focus on getting the job
you can't be distracted the bottom three
as you see them would be Jim penguin GM
and
Hikaru let's go check out jimas a little
bit well actually you know I I don't
know I mean honestly I could just sit
here I'm I'm I'm enthralled by the
process this is like you know I don't
know you get to see all the games at
once just like this is like a gen z a
gen Z dream they got enough content to
get their attention you know squirrel
squirrel like this is like they invented
all those Tik Tok videos now where like
like you're like watching some video
game while watching someone cook
salmon like what is going on here like
can we discuss can we discuss leaving
the frontal lobe alone yeah like can we
just give it a break for a second that's
a lot of that Jes ASMR stuff while
watching another video it's insane
absolutely crazy Tik Tok people are
tuning in for the drama
though oh the number of tabs on Tang's
browser get some
that is crazy yeah I have a feeling I
have a feeling that Jims is on his run
right now let's go to Jim let's go to
him the the small board come on baby oh
right as I said it I didn't knock on
wood now I feel bad I jinxed him but he
was at a minute 30 with 36 so he was
kind of slow to run okay that's fair and
that's kind of been Jim's you know again
it's hard to provide to provide
criticism for a guy who's been number
two competing rson for so many years in
a row but but that was always his thing
like there were many times where he
finished mid-50s perfect high 50s even
but he ran out of time and Ry Ry would
miss one or two but finish in the
mid-60s right there was just a different
level of speed that Ry was bringing to
the table again for those who uh maybe
haven't followed the last few years what
I noticed a lot from Ray too as well
something I actually started to do too
as well is a lot of times you just want
to go very fast in fact uh with the with
the puzzles here but Ray has just a very
he doesn't go as fast he just gets it
done but I'm gonna be very accurate very
accurate you can be quick in the first
20 or 30 or whatever you can be a few up
but then when it really starts to matter
he has a good pace and good flow where
he uh he takes his time when he needs to
I see that from right by the way I agree
we're gonna throw another Diamond
membership out there for for S day s7s
challenge whoever can correctly guess
the number of tabs open in Tang's
browser first ready set go go whoever
can guess the correct number now we're
gonna need mod confirmation on that
sorry staff I just gave you a job that's
irritating AF but you're gonna have to
check out let's get let's do it let's
give a big diamond
membership now the numbers are coming in
in fact we're gonna give six months six
months to the first person who guesses
it right that's right I'm half a
year feeling frisky six months is the
first person who guesses how many Tabs
are open for Andre
T oh man and then and then we also send
him a message in chat and let him know
that he's currently the subject of a
six-month giveaway Oprah showed up and
she's giving diamonds
away gotta ask how many tabs you got
open this is for research purposes okay
research only research purposes sir how
many tabs do you have
open I don't I don't think Tang could
answer there's no way T I don't know in
fact ah great answer great answer great
answer okay Jims has got 37 but this is
his Mo he's perfect but he's a little
slow and again again we're providing
loose criticism to someone who's an
absolute
baller um we've also got Hikaru on a
decent run right
now but still if it ended right now as
they were before they would stand Hans
Neeman and Christopher Yu would be
dancing that's crazy like he was you was
saying Hikaru and jemus like everybody's
thinking hikaro jemus hikaro Jus some
saying H some saying Christen for you
but I mean the numbers say Christopher
you and
hanses sorry I this is crazy these
puzzles are freaking nuts and hikaro
said that they've gotten harder yeah I
agree correct I don't know if y like I
don't know if Sunday is the day every
Sunday it feels like it's a whole new
site like y'all just put in new puzzles
every Sunday and like 8:00 p.m. Eastern
right before we go live it feels like
that boy is automatic every week new
badge yeah I asked I asked staff earlier
to to ask Roland I don't know that
anyone did it so I'm just going to go
ask Roland
myself you know tried to delegate how
many puzzles do we have in our database
total right now also I love you
Roland Happy New Year
it's been too long I miss
you also we're live on chess TV right
now there you go that's my message to
Roland let's go my twin brother H in
chat hello to hello H we look just alike
it's
crazy you and Bobby Hess big body Bobby
Hess we saw him swinging earlier that
was Robert's New Year resolution is he's
embracing the name Bobby I don't know if
you knew that Bobby okay
and I said it I said it it's going
online Robert can't take it back now
everyone now knows it man you've
embraced
it how all right here we go we've got
we've got four
people fighting for their lives
Christopher Yu would currently be moving
on along with Hans Neiman who both have
56 but these four as you see especially
Hikaru tang and Jims are all
they're under 10 minutes now to get the
job done this is this is this is epic
yeah this is definitely epic here guys
anything anything can shift all it takes
is at one run but it has to get done
under fatigue too as well fifth puzzle
Rush round you know 30 minutes each time
getting towards the end here guys are
fatiguing lot on the line This is a wild
round anything can happen this is by far
the toughest round super you you kind of
had an ominous feeling when when ROK
first kind of stole the spot from Hikaru
in round three and then it was POF who
sto the spot meaning they both had the
same score but both those players had
better tie breaks and you didn't I
mean this is not where you want to be
you've got some of the fastest mouses
mices in the in in the west left with
Andrew tang and Hans Neeman you've got
Jims who's an absolute Legend of puzzle
solving so this is for those rooting for
Hikaru which there are many send him to
flower power and uh
and I don't know what else to say yeah
right exactly we just let the puzzles do
the talking there is who is going to get
the number the the next there's only two
left two spots who is going to get it
it's it seems people have dialed in on
the number 67 that probably is correct
consist given the consistency some
people so someone's getting a six-month
Diamond membership and I'm getting a
lecture later Danny you're not allowed
to give away six months that's too long
you did tell me what I can't do dad you
you're not my dad I'm not your dad you
just have Daddy Issues Danny I don't
care leave me
alone it's gonna be okay Danny it's
gonna be okay you gotta re through you
gotta talk through these things man yeah
we do um yeah this is crazy I think Tang
is is on a is on a okay I just knocked
down oh my God he missed it right as I
knocked on wood I'm jinxing people I
need to Danny you need to shut your
mouth when you're talking to me what
your
mouth all right where we at any High
numbers there everything looking good
level nothing nothing
El it's hard not to go back to Hikaru
that's the biggest name it's the it's
the Man People are rooting for that's
true hear is having a tough time there
to his yeah he's having a tough time
he's missing he's missing puzzles in the
top 10 now he's tired he's saying he's
just terrible but he's not just terrible
he's
tired yeah but Jim is 98 would be going
home as well Hans Neeman and Christopher
Yu have punched their ticket Christopher
Yu is solving up there solving his
little heart out with a mouse instead of
an iPad kids grow up so fast you know
they right they grow up so
fast fast I don't know a computer what
is
that iPad
gang everybody go give these streamers a
follow that's uh that's something to do
always support everyone because three of
the four faces you see will be going
home after this round Hikaru could
really use your
follow I couldn't even say that without
laughing oh man that was
hilarious Carl could really use it small
streamer
there go support your small local
community.com
hikaro also GM hearo and twitch as well
streams on both mostly k
that's
right okay well we looking like five and
a
half we're looking at we're looking at
it
I I'm nervous we got five and a half
minutes I think at this point the nerves
are getting to them yeah five minutes
left brutal you know you you don't have
many shots left you do not have many
shots let's let's go to CaRu
stream I just knocked down wood not to
jinx
him this could be
it let's do
it wow what a puzzle
unfair
unfair it's got to be Queen F3 Queen F3
and then you take oh Queen G2 because
then of F5 you have G6 no what is it oh
that he found a night night over what is
this ohow King okay F3
he oh that was sick it's funny we saw
that puzzle earlier I don't remember who
had it but I saw someone solve it not
that I remember the answer takes what
it's not King takes all a stupid no what
in the world these puzzles are I know
Danny fix it come on bro this is unfair
gotta talk to the team man crazy
throwing them stupid look at that King
takes not the
move okay good news
everyone Roland says I love you too are
you screen sharing this also we have
822433 current approved and active
puzzles so we are not at a million oh my
goodness there are 822 th000 potentially
random puzzles to be served to anyone in
a puzzle Rush that's why this bleep is
hard 820,000 chat all it's going to take
a while you know but we can memorize all
right 100 years you know I think we
crossed the line that even even Ray
can't memorize um but yeah
so yeah this is this is this is a tired
Hikaru you can see it I think it might
be the writing on the wall at this point
and I don't want to dismiss anyone
because they're capable of greatness but
it looks like the final two may be
Christopher Yu and Hans Neeman if unless
someone can rise to the occasion
and get at least 56 and hope they have
good tiebreakers with three minutes here
on the clock it is possible but it takes
you know a lot of energy it also takes a
uh not you know get out of your own head
don't be negative about it as much as
you can it's kind of hard easier said
than done obviously 57 is a Herculean
task it's very hard to do but
possible wow by the way it has been
offici officially confirmed that it is
67 tabs and now the team is working on
who guessed it first one of you is
getting a massive Diamond membership 67
Taps what in the effing world of Shaban
Wisconsin is Andrew Tang doing 67
Taps 60 bro what what is open I have to
like we just have to figure this out
guys does anyone know what he has
open that he has to be 67 times
God this is this is so hard everything
we're watching is hard all right this is
it he's gonna try got he's got two more
runs left let's go quickly to bird's eye
view as hikaro gets started because this
is easy peasy beautiful Cover Girl this
show is not sponsored I think it was
easy breezy beautiful cover I I forget
the phrase it was some sort of saying
easy breezy beautiful anyway um but Jims
that's the one I just knocked on wood
not to jinx him I don't want to jinx
anybody but maybe we go tune in to the
the small board Master oh wait never
mind wait what did he just get he just
quit he just quit it because it wasn't
good enough
okay he quit it because he knew it
wasn't good enough a minute 20 chat oh
this is it this is it this is it this is
like very close chat predictions go
who's making it through predictions go
will Christopher you hold on joining
Hans Neeman in
tomorrow what will
happen
I don't
know because I don't have a crystal ball
and despite the accusations this is not
scripted this is not don't know who
y'all got come on chat under a minute
this is it if you do not have enough
time we gotta start over if you're
getting him wrong yeah let's see but
this you in a good spot so he just
restarted there but yeah this
is if anyone if anyone gets over 50
we'll zoom into them but right now I'm
just freaking
out freaking out I'm
nervous I wonder in my head does James
canny own any clothes that aren't tank
tops I don't know nope I don't
everywhere
like no but you know all my all my gear
now is all Gym gear it's all Coe like my
shirt pants socks literally my shoes are
all Coe gear like everything I have it's
pretty nice you're committed I'll say
that dedicated man the to shout out the
chat and thousands of orders y'all be
wearing the stuff at tournaments it's
crazy man it's everywhere I got to get
you some Danny I got to show you I'm
send you I'm in I'm into it you know
what I'm into it you know it I'm a try
I'm a try chess you will I'll try on any
chess position and and
clothing that is I mean it's 2024 chat
you know what I mean like hey you know
you can't judge me by Danny you can't
you can't you can't fact you can't do it
you can't man looking at this this is it
we're we're at zero
now oh my gosh nerve racking
AF well everyone is officially on their
last
run time's
up time is up
buttercup time is up Hikaru has
52 with 20 seconds left come on swing
clutch I guess3 with 14 when the
pressure's on no oh he's out oh
no oh man Valiant effort by Nakamura he
goes out swinging it was funny if it
wasn't for time he was right there and
and he just he kind of he kind of lost
it but hikara Nakamura that shows you
how tough the puzzle world is will not
be competing in day two of the puzzle
World Championship right I think we gota
I think we gotta stay here we got both
Jims and Tang up also both on their
final runs 56 or
better 56 or better to stay
alive oh man there you go you've got to
get 56 don't you know I don't know why
I'm singing It's always yeah it just
helps you know anything is going on you
just sing through it chat it's just it's
hey a lot of a lot of modern therapy
says that huming humming calms the brain
tapping calms the brain singing CMS the
brain I know a lot about mental health
techniques to walk yourself back off the
edge I I I know more than you'd want to
know okay I am I am I am currently
tackling the old problem known as mental
health in my life nice always always
tackle that that's a good place to be
what did he score there Andrew T
finished with a I think he actually
finished with a 53 tying the 53 we
already saw there but I think that's it
that's it for him too dang I think it's
in the books it's in the
books it's in the books
Chad there we go it's clear we're
clearing it out round five is in the
books you saw it there before we hit
reset on the scoreboard it is
Christopher Yu and Hans nean who will be
dancing I mean biggest surprise not
going on to to the final day you know
who it has to be it's got to okay well I
guess it's got to be hiar in the world
of content but it's it's it's Jim
98 jim9 every year every year he's been
in and now he's not every year every
year and hearo crazy yeah so as you see
there we'll get we'll get the final
eight bracket to remind you of all eight
who moved on here in a little bit but in
our round five it was Christopher hu and
Hans Neeman who both put up early 56s
that was interesting you could just see
the fatigue caught up to the other
players because because once Hans and
Chris got 56 they didn't do better than
that either but that was all they needed
nobody could muster a run better than
that right yeah I mean that and even in
the beginning there was that 60 ball
that um that um Ray Dro there which is
really nice but all that takes was hey
one good hot run and that's it
especially as the time goes on you
fatigue and we started to see that with
some of the players there and just back
toback runs and messing up and it just
wasn't he wasn't able to get it through
him meaning hikaro and also Jims as well
so congrats to Hans and Christopher con
congrats to Hans and Christopher in all
eight let's actually go through it real
quick because we've got the bracket for
you ready to roll remember earlier in
the day is when Ray put up the 60 but
the number one seed is Andy Woodward
because when we actually got to The
Knockout portion KY which was the top
20 it was Andy Woodward who put up the
best overall score which was
599 59 I remember that again the full
form was awesome today you missed it it
was fantastic we had 99 streamers show
up you had to be streaming to get in
next year we'll get over a 100 the top
20 moved on to the knockout stage and
every half an hour two people directly
qualified and three were sent home until
we had eight people left standing and
there they are Andy Woodward will take
on Hans nean tomorrow the other
youngster Liam putam will take on POF
you got ROK versus Jeffrey Jong that is
going to be a thriller from Manila and
killer and and we're going to move on
from that and then Ray Robson and
Christopher you all right and this is
going to be nice I mean cuz very nice
heated match up between all of those I
can't wait to see what Andy does the
being the top seed now now he has
something to really prove I'm 59 top
seed above big Ray have a nice day I
don't know how Ray feels about that one
but we definitely I don't know that's
this is this is fantastic you couldn't
write this better that you've got Andy
Woodward the 14-year-old going up as the
number one seed in tomorrow's Puzzle
Battle the final day of the 2024 puzzle
World Championship you know who else has
something to prove who else chess.com
Chief chess officer what who is that
idiot what an idiot that guy is what an
absolute dork face of a human being
Danny versus the world is going on right
now if you're not one of the I don't
know how many people we got we got a lot
of people in there voting and trying to
beat me we're we're about to simplify
into an interesting end game I'm hoping
there's one positional trick in the bag
that might beat the world give me some
long-term chances uh but at this point
I'm not going to lie I don't even know
if a draw is the worst result in the
world because I've lost every other game
I've ever played versus our Global chess
community so there you go use the
command play Danny we do give away swag
and prizes um some signed hats for the
first one and I've actually got a box of
hats right here in the studio maybe I'll
grab them I got a I gotta I gotta ship I
gotta ship some sign hats we got some
other merch that we're giving away but
you can join Danny versus the world
don't go anywhere you're going to want
to join us when we get back because we
are going to have an interview with the
number one seed for tomorrow a star of
tomorrow that's Andy Woodward don't go
anywhere it's your final moments from
the 2024 puzzle World Championship when
we
[Music]
return
look at that chess kid subtle branding
sticker on the
table I forgot Danny played this against
me and he won so I'm sure you're in good
hands
yep I think it was an accident I think I
was I think I blacked out for those
first two
games oh yeah
is
the L's prep I don't know are we in my
prep yes your prep if we're in my prep
I'm I'm really scared because you he's
moving with such confidence he doesn't
seem concerned whatsoever it's like it's
like really concern it's extremely
concerning I don't understand this is
secret prep your prep my prep actually I
think yeah this is actually prep or
maybe I just figured it out or maybe
it's a BL this U this is not my prep
actually the like so I have an option to
take that pun I wanted wait T is this
legit prep I have a suggestion Tony why
don't you take none of my PS I just take
none of them just not just don't take
any of my PS okay I won't take any of
your PS okay deal is a deal uh first
them to be taken
um wow this is actually crazy what this
position no actually yes yeah it is like
actually okay I mean this PR is pring
off wait a second wait a minute see yeah
this was what I was fearing when I
actually guys are playing this a little
too focused here for me are we supposed
to be like more
goofy supposed
to kind a
D7 why did I think about that move like
I mean this is all prep I mean look at
this I watched a video of you today
uhhuh before I was coming here I'm
really sorry and was about a Magnus
destroying everybody right were you
inspired and he yeah I was inspired and
he hanged the pawn or not hang he
sacrificed the pawn in the opening first
game um and he sacrificed the pawn to
have major counter play okay and I'm
inspired by this so I'm doing exactly
what he did but you're giving me way
more
than am I Maiden yes you
are am I really yes you are oh wait a
second oh my God yes you are I think I'm
missing my wallet it's not a good thing
everybody
y yay
everything that was an epic game what
are we doing we we we can't be awkward
we there you go we're going to be one of
those like epic like oh my gosh that was
that was just like this whole time I was
like my king is
[Music]
safe
you
[Music]
go
e
[Music]
I like
birds
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
say
sh
[Music]
w
a
[Music]
he
day one of the 2024 puzzle World
Championship is in the books what an
amazing few hours we had here Danny
wrench alongside James canny it's been a
it's been a wild ride big names didn't
make it to day two which is tomorrow
including hikaro Nakamura Jims 98 more
shocking than maybe anything uh canny so
many big things to take away let's bring
up the bracket and let you again dive
into your biggest surprise overall you
only get one only one biggest surprise
only one here that's a great one you
know what biggest surprise is Ray's not
number one that's the biggest surprise
here Ray big Ray and have a nice day
anytime anyway is not number one that's
my biggest surprise what about you get
that's that's a great pick I mean
honestly it's it's kind of crazy to
think about that
because he's he's not even number too
bro Jeff Jeffrey Jeong had the had
actually the uh the higher the higher
tie breaks as well I I I think and
that's that or was it ROK anyway what
what what a wild world we live in where
the goat of puzzles and and he is the
four-time reigning uh puzzle world
champion here on chess.com I I think
he's still the the heavy heavy heavy
favorite for tomorrow despite the
incredible performances by the
youngsters Andy Woodward Liam put among
others but that's a great call out I
think obviously hiar not dancing on day
two is disappointing for a lot of fans
but it's not that big of a surprise
given how difficult this particular
event is um I'm I'm gonna go with the
Jims storyline the fact that Jim is not
in the top eight kind of mind-blowing to
me yeah 100% Jims was like it was Ray
and then it was Jims and it was Ray
every year Ray Jims Ray Jims and then
this year it was Ray and everyone else
who we don't know Jims just didn't show
up this year it does happen sometimes it
just happens you can't win every time or
you can't be second every time either
but it does happen New Field new people
and some upsets and Jims was not able to
make it this year that's a shocker for
sure y speaking of new people Andy
Woodward is the new number one that
young 14-year-old International Master
put on a show today we talked about the
fact that he's he's currently being
sponsored by hikara Nakamura and his
overall chess career really impressive
stuff we tried to get him for an
interview we weren't able to pull it off
so for those of you been with us and I
teased it at the break apologize had
some technical difficulties so we will
not be catching up with Andy but who
knows maybe he wins the whole thing and
tomorrow we're talking with the kid uh
so we'll make sure that we get that we
get that worked out but all right I mean
Kenny I unfortunately have some personal
stuff with the kids doctor appointments
I got to go to Home Depot I got I got
Bed Bath and Beyond I think that was a
thing I I don't know I mean I got a busy
I got a busy Friday so I'm out you're
gonna have the call with amont Hamilton
how badly are you going to miss me it's
going to be bad man you know sometimes I
I didn't know how to control my emotions
now but I was going to cry but you know
I I know how to not do that so you I'm
gon hold that in you know how to not do
that okay so hold it in that's why you
got the
sunglasses hi those big tears when
they're coming down gota hide gotta hide
them baby yes sir y all right th this
has been awesome seriously a ton of fun
thank you to the community hanging out
with us in chat chat was super positive
supportive all day we got so much chess
ahead tomorrow so many puzzles ahead
remember it's The Puzzle Battle feature
these guys will see each other faing off
you should give that thing a try if if
you're not puzzle battling it's it's
going to be epic so all right tune in
tomorrow it's day two the final day of
the 2024 puzzle World Championship
experience Grandmaster ran Hamilton and
feed Master James KY will have the call
I will see everybody another time and
shout out to the crew and everyone who
made this possible until
then later everybody see you
[Music]
later
he
[Music]
d
I like your
[Music]
birs
oh
[Music]
say